Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest ishistory.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. the Tudor's transformed monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。想要获取每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问therestishistory.com并加入俱乐部。网址是therestishistory.com。本期节目由Hive赞助。你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转变为帝国，都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡村别墅。你知道吗？Hive也经历了自己的变革。大家都知道Hive以智能恒温器闻名，但现在他们已经进化得更加强大。太阳能电池板可以帮助你用清洁能源为家庭供电，热泵可以从空气中汲取热量。
EV chargers that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes, from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine's. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tap is in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply.
还有在你睡觉时为汽车充电的电动汽车充电桩。所有这些都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改变家庭的能力，从浪费到高效，从依赖到掌控，从消费到贡献。所以，历史下一次伟大的变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里，它可能就发生在你家里。一场没有断头台的宁静革命。Hive。掌控你的力量。访问hivehome.com了解更多。需视勘测和适用性而定，Hive应用程序兼容部分热泵。当你拥有美国运通白金卡时，你可以享受独家餐饮体验和年度旅行积分。所以，城里最好的餐厅可能就在一个全新的城市。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。适用条款和条件。
Learn more at mx.ca. slash yamex. Rinse takes your laundry and hand delivers it to your door, expertly cleaned and folded. So you could take the time once spent folding and sorting and waiting to finally pursue a whole new version of you. Like tea time you. Mmm.
在mx.ca/yamex了解更多。Rinse负责你的洗衣，并将其手工送到你家门口，经过专业清洗和折叠。这样你就可以把曾经花在折叠、分类和等待上的时间，用来追求一个全新的自己。比如下午茶时间的你。嗯。
Or this tea time you. Or even this tea time you. Said you hear about Dave? Or even tea time, tea time, tea time you. Mmm. So update on Dave. It's up to you. We'll take the laundry.
或者这个下午茶时间的你。甚至这个下午茶时间的你。听说戴夫的事了吗？或者甚至是下午茶时间、下午茶时间、下午茶时间的你。嗯。关于戴夫的最新消息。这取决于你。我们来负责洗衣。
Rince, it's time to be great. When it was time to go, Nelson went up alone to the bedroom, where little Horatia lay fast asleep. For a while, he knelt in silent prayer by her bedside. then very gently he kissed her on the forehead and went downstairs his boxes had been loaded aboard the coach emma was crying harder than ever now again nelson knelt on the ground in prayer and asked god to bless her for the last time he clasped her to his chest brave emma heroic emma you encourage me to go forth he said gently. If there were more emmers, there would be more Nelson's. Then he climbed up into the coach and raised his left hand, and he was gone.
Rinse，是时候变得伟大了。当出发的时间到了，纳尔逊独自上楼来到卧室，小霍拉蒂亚正熟睡着。有一会儿，他跪在床边默默祈祷。然后他非常温柔地亲吻了她的额头，走下楼去。他的行李箱已经装上了马车。艾玛现在哭得比以往任何时候都厉害。纳尔逊再次跪在地上祈祷，最后一次请求上帝保佑她。他把她紧紧搂在怀里。“勇敢的艾玛，英雄的艾玛，你鼓励我前行，”他温柔地说。“如果多一些艾玛，就会多一些纳尔逊。”然后他爬上马车，举起左手，他就这样离开了。
Afterwards, Nelson wrote in his journal, Friday night, at half-past ten, drove from dear, dear Merton, where I left all which I hold dear in this world to go to serve my king and country. May the great God whom I adore enable me to fill the expectations of my country. And if it is his good pleasure that I should return, my thanks will never cease being offered up to the throne of his mercy. If it is his good providence to cut short my days upon earth, I bow
之后，纳尔逊在日记中写道：“周五晚上十点半，从亲爱的、亲爱的默顿出发，我离开了在这个世界上我所珍视的一切，去为我的国王和国家服务。愿我所崇拜的伟大上帝使我能够满足国家的期望。如果这是他的美意，让我能够归来，我将永不停息地向他的仁慈宝座献上感谢。如果这是他伟大的天意，要缩短我在世上的日子，我鞠躬
with the greater submission, relying that he will protect those so dear to me that I leave behind. His will be done. Amen, amen, amen. An unbelievably moving scene. I mean, how I got through that without choking up, I do not know. It's the last farewell of Horatio Nelson to his beloved Emma, Lady Hamilton, and their daughter Horatia on the evening of the 13th of September 1805.
并更加顺从，相信他会保护我留下的那些我所珍视的人。愿他的旨意成就。阿门，阿门，阿门。”这是一个令人难以置信的感人场景。我的意思是，我不知道自己是怎么在不哽咽的情况下读完这段话的。这是霍雷肖·纳尔逊在1805年9月13日晚上，与他挚爱的艾玛、汉密尔顿夫人以及他们的女儿霍拉蒂亚的最后告别。
Dominic, it has been described many times. But I doubt it has ever been described in more powerful and emotional terms than in that passage of prose, which comes from Adventures in Time, Nelson, Hero of the Seas, and you don't need me to tell you that you wrote it. And can I just compliment you on giving proper credence to Emma's report of his parting words to her? If there were more Emmas, there would be more Nelson's because there are some black-hearted biographers who have doubted that he ever said that. It's the kind of melodramatic thing that Nelson would say there, isn't it? I agree. I absolutely think he said it. The thing is, I'm not a massive Lady Hamilton fan, as you know, but it strikes me as
多米尼克，这一幕已经被描述过很多次了。但我怀疑，除了《时间冒险：纳尔逊，海洋英雄》中的那段散文，恐怕再没有比这更强大、更感人的描述了，而且不用我说你也知道，那是你写的。我能称赞一下你对艾玛转述他临别赠言的重视吗？“如果多一些艾玛，就会多一些纳尔逊”，因为有一些心怀叵测的传记作家怀疑他是否真的说过这句话。这听起来确实是纳尔逊会说的那种戏剧性的话，不是吗？我同意。我绝对认为他说了。问题是，如你所知，我不是汉密尔顿夫人的超级粉丝，但我觉得
absolutely plausible that Nelson turned his departure. Both of them actually turned his departure into this enormously sort of melodramatic theatrical spectacle. And actually, that's what this week's episodes are going to be, a massively melodramatic theatrical spectacle, because it is, I think, the most dramatic, most exciting, the most most emotionally charged story in naval history, arguably in all British history, Nelson's last voyage to the Day of Destiny at Trafalgar. And the measure of that is that we've already done it once. So this is, I think, is really
纳尔逊将他的离别变成这样一种极其戏剧化的场面是完全合理的。他们俩实际上都把他的离别变成了一场极其夸张的戏剧表演。事实上，这正是本周剧集的内容，一场极其夸张的戏剧表演，因为我认为这是海军史上，甚至可以说是整个英国历史上最戏剧性、最激动人心、最充满情感的故事，纳尔逊前往特拉法加命运之日的最后航行。衡量这一点的标准是，我们已经讲过一次了。所以我想，这真的是
the only great story that we're retelling. But this time we're telling it with the focus on Nelson himself, aren't we? Yeah, because last time, when we did three episodes about Trafalgar, we looked at it in a sort of, we brought all our knowledge of naval military history. rope, guns, ships of the line. But now we're bringing our psychological insight to discuss it from Nelson's own perspective, aren't we? At least that's the excuse. So the great man will always be in the foreground.
唯一一个我们重述的伟大故事。但这一次我们讲述它的重点是纳尔逊本人，对吧？是的，因为上次我们做关于特拉法加的三集节目时，我们是从海军军事历史的角度来看待它的。绳索、大炮、战列舰。但现在我们带来了心理洞察，从纳尔逊自己的视角来讨论它，对吧？至少这是个借口。所以这位伟人将始终处于前景之中。
And maybe for those people who've been on this voyage with us from the beginning, we can just do a little recap. So last time, Tom, we ended July 1805. And to quote Russell Crowe in Master and Commander, England is under threat of invasion. So after two years... It's not a laughing matter. No, it's not, actually.
也许对于那些从一开始就和我们一起踏上这段旅程的人，我们可以做一个小小的回顾。所以上次，汤姆，我们结束于1805年7月。引用《怒海争锋》中罗素·克劳的话，英国正受到入侵的威胁。所以经过两年……这不是一件可笑的事情。不，确实不是。
I shouldn't be laughing. I'm laughing to stop myself sobbing with patriotic. Exactly. So after two years at sea, Nelson has pursued the combined fleet of France and Spain under Pierre-Charles-Villeuve and Frederico Gravina all the way to the Caribbean and all the way back. And Villeneuve has holed up in the northern Spanish port of Ferrol. So the threat has faded for the time being. It's been bottled up, but it hasn't completely disappeared.
我不该笑的。我笑是为了阻止自己因爱国情怀而啜泣。没错。所以经过两年的海上航行，纳尔逊一直在追逐皮埃尔-查尔斯·维尔纳夫和费德里科·格拉维纳率领的法西联合舰队，一直追到加勒比海，又追了回来。而维尔纳夫躲进了西班牙北部的费罗尔港。所以威胁暂时消退了。它被封锁住了，但并没有完全消失。
And that gives Nelson the chance, after all these years at sea, on his blockading mission, to go home at last to see his beloved Emma, and he lands in Portsmouth on Monday, the 19th of August. And when he gets there, there's a reprise of what's been a feature of his landing in England, which is the determination of people to unhitch the horses from his carriage and to carry him, to pull him himself while doing hussars. And it's the measure of how desperate Nelson is to get back to Emma.
这让纳尔逊在经历了这么多年的海上封锁任务后，终于有机会回家看看他挚爱的艾玛。他在8月19日星期一抵达朴茨茅斯。当他到达那里时，重演了他抵达英国时的一个特色，那就是人们决心解开他马车的马匹，亲自拉着他，一边高呼万岁。这是衡量纳尔逊多么渴望回到艾玛身边的一个标准。
But this time when they try and unyoke the horses, he won't let them because he's desperate to get off. And he's not having any of this business. You were telling me before we started recording that you were hoping that Australians would do this for us when we arrived in Australia for our rest of history tour. That's right, isn't it? We'd love some hussaring.
但这次当他们试图解开马匹时，他不让他们这样做，因为他急着离开。他不想搞这一套。我们在开始录音前你告诉我，你希望澳大利亚人在我们到达澳大利亚进行《历史的余味》巡演时能为我们这样做。没错，是这样吧？我们很乐意有人高呼万岁。
Definitely. And people pulling us. pulling the carriage. I think that's very important. Anyway, so he sets off, he rushes to Merton, and early the next day, his coach turns into the new carriageway that has been built at Merton Place. Now, Emma has been waiting anxiously for him for two years. She's been sea bathing in South End on Sea, which has become massively popular in England. So Brighton is the famous place where people go to do it. And Emma had actually become a fan of bathing in Italy because Sir William Hamilton, her husband, had brought her a bathing machine
当然。还有人拉着马车。我认为这非常重要。总之，他出发了，冲向默顿，第二天一早，他的马车转进了默顿庄园新建的车道。艾玛已经焦急地等了他两年了。她一直在滨海绍森德进行海水浴，这在英国已经变得非常流行。布莱顿是人们去进行海水浴的著名地方。而艾玛实际上在意大利时就成了海水浴的粉丝，因为她的丈夫威廉·汉密尔顿爵士给她带了一台洗澡机
from England so that she could protect her complexion from the Italian sun. So she's ferrier fay with bathing. How does the machine protect you from the sun? I think you drive it out, don't you? And so you put your feet out and protects you. But you're basically covered by some form of roof. I don't know. I'm being ambushed here by questions about bathing machines. Yeah, yeah. You shouldn't have put that detail in if you weren't prepared to explore it. Yeah, I know, I know. Well, anyway, she rushes home. She's incredibly excited. And she has arranged on hearing the news of his return to have Horatia, who is now four, brought from Mrs. Gibson, who is her kind of guardian. So Nelson, when he arrives at Merton, he is absolutely overjoyed to see. Horatia in particular, who he hasn't officially acknowledged as his own, has he? No, but he really dotes on her. He makes arrangements for her to go to Sunday school. He is, of course, course, the son of a vicar, so he takes that very seriously. I think there's an expectation,
从英国带去的，这样她就可以保护自己的肤色免受意大利阳光的伤害。所以她对洗澡很在行。那机器是怎么保护你不受阳光伤害的？我想你是把它开出去，对吧？然后你把脚伸出来，它就保护你了。但你基本上是被某种屋顶覆盖着。我不知道。我在这里被关于洗澡机的问题伏击了。是啊，是啊。如果你没准备好探讨它，就不应该把那个细节放进去。是啊，我知道，我知道。好吧，总之，她冲回家。她非常兴奋。在听到他回来的消息后，她安排把现在四岁的霍拉蒂亚从她的监护人吉布森夫人那里接来。所以纳尔逊到达默顿后，看到霍拉蒂亚特别高兴，他还没有正式承认她是自己的孩子，对吧？不，但他真的很宠爱她。他安排她去主日学校。他当然是牧师的儿子，所以他对此非常认真。我想有一种期望，
don't you, that he would like Horatia to live with them permanently, and Merton from this point onwards. And he's also thrilled with the house. I mentioned the new carriageway. Emma has done a lot of work in the last two years on the house. Sort of grand designs have been in, and she has got a new kitchen, there's a new library, loads of new pictures of Nelson and herself. That's the key The key thing I mean basically There were kind of two houses
你不觉得吗？他希望霍拉蒂亚能和他们永久住在一起，从这一点开始就在默顿。他也对房子感到非常激动。我提到了新的车道。艾玛在过去两年里对房子做了很多工作。某种宏大的设计已经完成，她有了一个新厨房，一个新的图书馆，还有很多纳尔逊和她自己的新照片。这是关键。关键是，我的意思是基本上有两栋房子
And she's knitted them together And she's bought up lots of estates around it So that it's a much more Pre-possessing place than when Nelson had left And she fancied herself as a garden designer as well Because Nelson I think said she was a regular capability brown Or something of that ilk There's no end to her talents
她把它们缝合在一起了。她买下了周围的许多地产。所以它比纳尔逊离开时更令人印象深刻。她还自认为是园林设计师，因为纳尔逊我想说她是常规的“能力布朗”或类似的人。她的才华无穷无尽。
Yeah amazing But actually Nelson doesn't spend as much time At Merton as he would like Because his main business is in London The very next day after arriving in Merton, he goes into London to meet various kind of big wigs from the government and the Admiralty, Chief among them, William Pitt, Pitt the Younger, who is Prime Minister, and the new Secretary of State for War, who is Lord Castle Ray.
是的，太棒了。但实际上纳尔逊在默顿待的时间并没有他想要的那么多，因为他的主要事务在伦敦。到达默顿的第二天，他就去伦敦会见政府和海军部的各种大人物，其中最主要的是威廉·皮特，小皮特，他是首相，还有新的战争大臣卡斯尔雷勋爵。
And when he gets there, Nelson is quite anxious that people will give him a lot of grief for failing to catch a feel nerve, because that, of course, was his ambition to catch up with the combined fleet and to destroy it. So he's a little bit anxious people will say, gosh, you've let us down. But actually when he gets there to London, he finds that the newspapers are hailing him as the man who has saved the Caribbean for Britain, the West Indian colony, basically the sugar islands, which are so important to Britain's economic prosperity. Well, I mean, also, I think they're recognising the scale of his accomplishment in keeping his fleet together under such grueling circumstances and ensuring that Villeneuve can't do anything. Yeah, I think that's completely right. I think he is now at this point.
当他到达那里时，纳尔逊很担心人们会因为他没能抓住维尔纳夫而责怪他，因为那当然是他追赶联合舰队并摧毁它的雄心。所以他有点担心人们会说，天哪，你让我们失望了。但实际上当他到达伦敦时，他发现报纸都在称赞他是拯救了加勒比海为英国的人，西印度群岛，基本上是糖岛，这对英国的经济繁荣非常重要。嗯，我的意思是，我也认为他们是在承认他在如此艰苦的情况下保持舰队团结并确保维尔纳夫无法采取任何行动的成就规模。是的，我认为这完全正确。我想他现在在这一点上。
We've talked in previous episodes about things like when he went to. on a kind of progress around the countryside and people were hailing him and stuff. He is a genuine celebrity. He is the supreme patriotic hero. So an American tourist afterwards described seeing him in the Strand. His sunburned, of course, because he's been a sea all this time. He walks with the sailors gate, so he has this amusing sort of rolling walk. And this American said, when he enters a shop, the door is thronged till he comes out,
我们在之前的剧集中谈到过，比如当他在乡村进行某种巡游时，人们在欢呼他等等。他是一个真正的名人。他是至高无上的爱国英雄。所以一位美国游客后来描述在河岸街看到他。他被晒黑了，当然，因为他一直待在海上。他走着水手的步态，所以他有一种有趣的摇摆步态。这位美国人说，当他走进一家商店时，门口挤满了人，直到他出来，
when the air rings with Hazars and the dark cloud of the populace again moves on and hangs upon his skirts. He's a great favourite with all descriptions of people. He's going to be like us in Sydney. It is very similar scenes, actually. And his mate Lord Minto, whom we've encountered previously being extremely disparaging about the menage of Merton and the interior decoration. Lord Minto came across him in Piccadilly and found him mobbed by a crowd and actually went into the crowd to kind of get him out and said afterwards it was affecting to see. see the wonder and admiration and love and respect of the whole world the moment he has seen. It's beyond anything represented in a play or a poem.
空气中回荡着万岁声，黑暗的人群又移动起来，挂在他的衣角上。他是各行各业人们的最爱。他会像我们在悉尼一样。实际上场景非常相似。他的朋友明托勋爵，我们之前遇到过他，他对默顿的家务和室内装饰非常贬低。明托勋爵在皮卡迪利大街偶遇他，发现他被人群围住，实际上还走进人群把他拉出来，事后说看到这一幕很感人。看到全世界对他那种惊奇、钦佩、爱戴和尊重，那一刻他被看到了。这超出了戏剧或诗歌中的任何表现。
And I think also for the Admiralty, they are also affected by this, aren't they? The sense that he is something more now than just an admiral or an officer to be slotted into a chain of command, that his fame and his charisma have transcended that. that he is the person inevitably that they're going to turn to when and if the great moment of crisis comes. Yeah, he's become, from being a slightly difficult asset, which he was a couple of years ago, he's now more than that, isn't he?
而且我认为对于海军部来说，他们也受到了这种影响，不是吗？那种感觉是，他现在不仅仅是一个海军上将或一个可以被塞进指挥链的军官，他的名声和魅力已经超越了这一点。他不可避免地成为当重大危机时刻到来时他们会求助的人。是的，他已经从几年前一个稍微有点麻烦的资产，变成了现在的样子，不是吗？
He's the embodiment of the naval spirit itself. Yeah, he's an icon. Yeah. Now, I think to make sense of this, you have to see Nelson as part of a sort of a dichotomy. You've got Nelson on one side, and you have Napoleon on the other. Because just as people are swooning before Nelson, hatred of Napoleon Bonabard has now reached an absolute peak in Britain.
他是海军精神本身的化身。是的，他是一个偶像。是的。现在，我认为要理解这一点，你必须把纳尔逊看作某种二分法的一部分。你有一边的纳尔逊，另一边的拿破仑。因为就在人们在纳尔逊面前倾倒时，对拿破仑·波拿巴的仇恨现在在英国达到了绝对的顶峰。
So the newspapers paint him, which had actually not been entirely unadmiring in the 1790s, now paint him as this sort of Corsican dwarf, as I quote, a plunderer and murderer with a malignant spirit, a depraved imagination and a heart black with crimes of the deepest die. Our prosperity and glory, our opposition to his schemes of universal conquest, rankle in his mind and prey upon his heart, exciting that deadly enmity which would drown our island with blood. So Napoleon as the bogey man is now at his absolute height. But I mean, it's kind of interesting because obviously there are people who still admire Napoleon,
所以报纸描绘他，实际上在1790年代并非完全不钦佩，现在把他描绘成某种科西嘉侏儒，正如我引用的，“一个掠夺者和杀人犯，有着恶毒的精神，堕落的想象力和一颗因最深重的罪恶而变黑的心。我们的繁荣和荣耀，我们对他普遍征服计划的反对，在他的心中怨恨并吞噬着他的心，激起那种会用鲜血淹没我们岛屿的致命敌意。”所以拿破仑作为妖怪现在处于绝对的高度。但我的意思是，这很有趣，因为显然仍然有人钦佩拿破仑，
and this will be the case right the way throughout the Napoleonic Wars. So Byron is a kind of famous example. But even Byron at Myers-Nelson, I think even, the people at Holland House, the supporters of Fox and all these people, the Whigs, even they sense that in Nelson they have someone who is a kind of transcendently charismatic figure. And I think for the mass of the public, you know, the great sweep of European history is reduced in their minds, as simplified in their minds into a clash between these two men. And a lot of this is because London is now in the grip of a full-blown invasion panic.
这种情况在整个拿破仑战争期间都会存在。所以拜伦就是一个著名的例子。但即使是拜伦也钦佩纳尔逊，我想即使是荷兰之家的那些人，福克斯的支持者和所有这些人，辉格党人，即使他们也感觉到在纳尔逊身上，他们拥有一个具有超越性魅力的人物。而且我认为对于广大公众来说，你知道，欧洲历史的巨大浪潮在他们的脑海中被简化了，简化为这两个人之间的冲突。而这很大程度上是因为伦敦现在正处于全面入侵恐慌的控制之中。
So there are multiple invasion panics during the French Revolution and the Napoleonic Wars. This one has been building since the war resumed in 1803. It's fueled by all these kind of Gilray cartoons and newspaper articles and so on. And, you know, you would see everywhere in London if you walk around pictures of all the French schemes, sort of massive paddle boats and fleets of balloons, a channel tunnel, all of this stuff. Yes, and I think that that's a kind of subliminal memory that carried right the way up to the building of the actual channel tunnel that it's this now. People are kind of nervous about... The French will attack us. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, they were. Completely they were. And it's
在法国大革命和拿破仑战争期间，曾多次出现入侵恐慌。这次恐慌自1803年战争重启以来就一直在酝酿。它受到吉尔雷（Gilray）的各种漫画、报纸文章等内容的推波助澜。你知道，如果你在伦敦四处走走，到处都能看到关于法国人各种阴谋的图片，比如巨大的明轮船、气球舰队、海峡隧道等等。是的，我认为这是一种潜意识的记忆，一直延续到后来真正修建海峡隧道的时候，现在也是如此。人们对“法国人会攻击我们”感到有些紧张。是的，确实如此。是的，他们确实很紧张。而且，
easy for us to laugh at it and say, oh, this is overblown because we know the invasion didn't happen. But there were very good reasons for people to be frightened. I mean, just to get into the invasion panic, you know, the mood that Nelson encounters when he returns in 1805. If the French ever got across the channel, they would be pretty much unstoppable. Britain has only a tiny army. What army it had, what professional army it had, had had been devastated. by a failed invasion of Haiti in the 1790s, and has never really been rebuilt. Napoleon's army, by contrast, the most formidable machine in Europe, they've destroyed every enemy in their path, they've left a trail of blood behind them, plundering and sacking all
我们很容易嘲笑这一点，说这太夸张了，因为我们知道入侵并没有发生。但当时人们感到恐惧是有充分理由的。我的意思是，单就入侵恐慌而言，你知道，纳尔逊1805年回来时所感受到的那种氛围。如果法国人真的跨过了海峡，他们几乎是不可阻挡的。英国只有一支微小的军队。它所拥有的那点职业军队，在18世纪90年代对海地的入侵失败后就已经被摧毁了，而且从未真正重建过。相比之下，拿破仑的军队是欧洲最强大的战争机器，他们摧毁了沿途的每一个敌人，留下一路血迹，掠夺和洗劫了
these towns and villages in Italy and so on. And it's understandable that people think, if the French ever did get across the channel, the consequences will be nightmarish for Britain. But also, they only need control of the channel for a day to land their forces. And then essentially Britain would be knocked out of the war. So there was a marshal of Napoleon, André Massena, who said, we were never going to conquer Britain. No one even dreamt of it. It was just a question of ruining it, of leaving it in a condition that no one would ever have wanted to possess it.
意大利等地的所有城镇和村庄。人们认为，如果法国人真的跨过了海峡，对英国来说后果将是噩梦般的，这是可以理解的。而且，他们只需要控制海峡一天就能让部队登陆。那么本质上，英国就会被踢出战争。所以，拿破仑的一位元帅安德烈·马塞纳（André Massena）曾说，我们从来没打算征服英国。没人想过这件事。这只是为了摧毁它，让它处于一种没人会想要占有的状态。
And essentially, that would mean destroying the dockyards, so Portsmouth. Well, Chatham, of course. And Chatham would have been right in the pathway. A place so close to your heart. Yeah. So I think it's not entirely unjustified. I mean, the stakes are high. If the Royal Navy loses control of the seas, Britain is sunk.
本质上，这意味着摧毁造船厂，比如朴茨茅斯。当然还有查塔姆。查塔姆本会处于入侵的必经之路上。一个离你心很近的地方。是的。所以我认为这并非完全没有道理。我的意思是，赌注很高。如果皇家海军失去了对海洋的控制，英国就完了。
Yeah, that's marine metaphor there Tom. That's what I'm all about. So by August 1805, all of this has reached a climax. Napoleon assembles his invasion force. It's French, Dutch and Bavarian armies. They're camped along the coast, the channel, all the way from Boulogne eastwards to Antwerp, including the French cavalry and the Imperial Guard. So the very kind of cream of the Napoleonic War Machine. And on the 20th of August, so that's just the day after I think Nelson has returned, he has a formal inspection in Boulogne. And there is a plan. I mean, the plan has been made, that there would be a first wave of more than 100,000 men in 2,000 transports, and then a second wave of 50,000 men in another 600 transports. Now, we know that they don't come, and a lot of historians say it was actually never going to work this plan, but nobody knows this in Britain. And the newspapers in August 1805 are telling their readers, and I quote, the movements on the French French coast have given rise to the belief that the invasion of England will be attempted immediately.
是的，那是海洋隐喻，汤姆。这就是我的风格。所以到了1805年8月，这一切都达到了高潮。拿破仑集结了他的入侵部队。那是法国、荷兰和巴伐利亚的军队。他们驻扎在沿海，从布洛涅向东一直到安特卫普，包括法国骑兵和帝国卫队。也就是拿破仑战争机器的精华。在8月20日，也就是我认为纳尔逊回来的第二天，他在布洛涅进行了一次正式视察。而且有一个计划。我的意思是，计划已经制定好了，第一波将有超过10万名士兵乘坐2000艘运输船，然后是第二波5万名士兵乘坐另外600艘运输船。现在，我们知道他们没有来，很多历史学家说这个计划实际上根本行不通，但在英国没人知道这一点。1805年8月的报纸告诉读者，我引用一下：“法国海岸的动向引起了人们的猜测，即入侵英国的企图将立即实施。”
So there are all kinds of plans that have been made, a series of what are called optical telegraphs to link the admiralty with Chatham, Tom, with Shieness, with all these. So these are people like waving flags and stuff to communicate with each other on hills. There are beacons. There are coastal batteries. They are working on the Martello towers, which actually don't get finished until after the Battle of Trafalgar. And, Domney, what about the sea fensibles?
所以制定了各种各样的计划，一系列所谓的“光学电报”来连接海军部和查塔姆、希尔内斯以及所有这些地方。所以这些就是人们在山上挥舞旗帜之类的东西来互相交流。还有烽火台。还有海岸炮台。他们正在建造马特洛塔（Martello towers），实际上直到特拉法尔加海战之后才完工。还有，多姆尼，海防民兵（Sea Fencibles）怎么样了？
Well, the sea fence walls are the absolute crack troops, aren't they? People with one leg, disgruntled fishermen, angers, whatever. Touching heads. They've been called out. And actually, I have to say, almost 400,000 volunteers are drilling as Nelson arrives. You know, so people genuinely think this is going to happen. There are contingency plans to close the stock exchange to safeguard the gold reserves and the Bank of England, even to move the king and the government to the Midlands, should the French actually manage to land. Now, William Pitt and Coe know that the control of the channel is what this is all about. And that's, of course, why London had been thrown into panic by the news of Villeneuve and Gravina forming the combined. fleet, because the combined fleet would outnumber Nelson's fleet. And they were also furious with this bloke, this a bloke called Robert Calder, who had
嗯，海防民兵是绝对的精锐部队，不是吗？只有一条腿的人、心怀不满的渔民、垂钓者等等。碰头会议。他们已经被征召了。而且我必须说，在纳尔逊抵达时，有近40万名志愿者正在进行操练。你知道，所以人们真的认为这会发生。有应急计划关闭证券交易所，以保护黄金储备和英格兰银行，甚至在法国人真的设法登陆的情况下，将国王和政府转移到中部地区。现在，威廉·皮特（William Pitt）和他的同僚们知道，控制海峡才是这一切的关键。当然，这就是为什么伦敦在听到维尔纳夫（Villeneuve）和格拉维纳（Gravina）组成联合舰队的消息后陷入恐慌的原因，因为联合舰队在数量上会超过纳尔逊的舰队。他们还对一个叫罗伯特·卡尔德（Robert Calder）的家伙感到愤怒，他
intercepted Veilnerf on his way home and basically allowed him to escape to Ferrell. And so everyone is saying, oh, this guy, Calder is useless, which is actually very unfair, because the combined fleet should have been killed off. It shouldn't have been allowed to get safe into port. But it is a reminder of the absolute assumption that it's a duty of a Royal Navy officer to attack, which has been the case ever since poor old Admiral Bing got shot on the deck of his own boat to encourage the others, as Voltaire put it. So this is all the context to explain why Nelson's return home is such a popular sensation
在维尔纳夫回家的路上拦截了他，基本上让他逃到了费罗尔。所以每个人都在说，哦，这个家伙卡尔德真没用，这其实很不公平，因为联合舰队本应该被消灭的。不应该让他们安全进入港口。但这提醒了人们一个绝对的假设，即攻击是皇家海军军官的职责，自打可怜的老海军上将宾（Admiral Byng）在自己的船甲板上被枪决以“鼓励其他人”（正如伏尔泰所言）以来，情况一直如此。所以这就是解释为什么纳尔逊回国会引起如此轰动的全部背景，
and why there is such a tremendous sense of mounting tension and excitement of events speeding towards a showdown. John Sugden, in his brilliant biography of Nelson, has some excellent lines on this. He says, nowhere that summer could Nelson escape the feeling that he was in the center of a huge unfolding drama, inexorably gathering pace towards some historic climax. He was the country's champion, arming himself for the decisive contest. And I think we talked about this before, but I think he genuinely feels that he is kind of God's champion in this, that there is a kind of apocalyptic tinge to the whole drama that
以及为什么会有如此巨大的紧张感和兴奋感，事件正加速走向摊牌。约翰·萨格登（John Sugden）在他那本精彩的纳尔逊传记中对此有一些精彩的描述。他说，那个夏天，纳尔逊无论在哪里都无法摆脱一种感觉，即他正处于一场巨大的、正在展开的戏剧中心，不可阻挡地向某个历史性的高潮加速迈进。他是国家的捍卫者，正为决定性的较量武装自己。我想我们之前谈过这个，但我认为他真的觉得他是上帝在这一事件中的捍卫者，整个戏剧有一种末日般的色彩，
is brewing. I think so. I think he thinks, listen, this is now, this is it now. if I can destroy the combined fleet, that is it, the war at sea is over, it is done, Britain is the mistress of the seas, end of story. And actually, in that case, the Royal Navy can take over the French and Spanish trade, it can blockade their ports, and over time we can squeeze Napoleon into surrender. And basically, that is what happens. That is what happens. And that doctrine of annihilation, I mean, again, we've talked about this throughout the series,
正在酝酿之中。我想是的。我想他认为，听着，就是现在，就是现在了。如果我能摧毁联合舰队，那就是了，海上的战争就结束了，一切都完成了，英国就是海洋的女主人，故事结束。实际上，在这种情况下，皇家海军可以接管法国和西班牙的贸易，可以封锁他们的港口，随着时间的推移，我们可以迫使拿破仑投降。基本上，这就是后来发生的事情。这就是发生的事情。那种歼灭主义，我的意思是，我们在这个系列中一直谈论这个，
it's one that Nelson absolutely upholds, but it is also essentially Royal Navy dogma and increasingly getting up close blasting the enemy ships out of the water this is becoming the orthodoxy but it takes Nelson to enshrine it and to reveal the full devastating impact that it can have. Yeah, I think that's right.
这是纳尔逊绝对坚持的，但它本质上也是皇家海军的教条，并且越来越接近于近距离将敌舰炸出水面，这正成为正统观念，但需要纳尔逊来将其奉为圭臬，并揭示它所能产生的全面破坏性影响。是的，我想那是对的。
I think all this time he's turning over the plan in his mind what he'll do. He knows when the showdown will come and he's thinking how will I do this? There's a very, very famous story. Guy who Captain Richard Keats visited Merton, and Nelson went for a walk with him and said, okay, here is the plan.
我想这段时间他一直在脑海中反复思考这个计划，他会怎么做。他知道摊牌何时会到来，他在想我该怎么做？有一个非常、非常著名的故事。基茨（Keats）船长拜访了默顿（Merton），纳尔逊和他一起散步，说，好吧，这就是计划。
I will go straight at the combined fleet when I see them. I'll have two attacking columns to splinter their line. He says, what do you think of it? I'll tell you what I think of it. I think it will surprise and confound the enemy. They won't know what I'm about. It will bring forward a pell-mell battle, and that's what I want. So get in really close and go for it.
当我看到联合舰队时，我会直接冲向他们。我会用两列攻击纵队来粉碎他们的阵线。他说，你觉得怎么样？我告诉你我的想法。我认为这会使敌人感到惊讶和困惑。他们不知道我要做什么。这会带来一场混战，而这正是我想要的。所以要靠得非常近，然后全力出击。
So Adam Nicholson, in his brilliant book on Trafalgar, describes it as the introduction. of chaos as a tool of battle because the kind of the traditional naval battle is like a kind of a waltz a minuet like the kind of thing that you see in a Jane Austen adaptation his plan is to totally upend that and in the conditions of chaos
所以亚当·尼科尔森（Adam Nicholson）在他那本关于特拉法尔加的精彩著作中将其描述为“将混乱作为战斗工具的引入”，因为传统的各种海战就像一种华尔兹、一种小步舞曲，就像你在简·奥斯汀改编作品中看到的那种东西，他的计划是彻底颠覆这一点，并在混乱的条件下
rely on the fact that British gunnery is so superior that the Royal Navy ships will inevitably emerge triumphant but will he get the chance this is the question so all the time he's waiting and waiting and waiting for news and then a final At 5 o'clock in the morning, on Monday the 2nd of September, a coach in four comes rattling down the drive towards Merton Place. And out gets this naval officer, he's quite a stocky bloke.
依靠英国炮术如此优越的事实，皇家海军的舰船将不可避免地取得胜利。但他会有机会吗？这是个问题。所以他一直在等待，等待，等待消息，然后最后在9月2日星期一早上5点，一辆四马马车沿着车道向默顿庄园疾驰而来。走下来的是这位海军军官，他是个相当结实的家伙。
He's come all the way by sea and by land, so he's covered with seawater and mud. And this guy is called Henry Blackwood. And he is the captain of the frigate Uriolus. And he has come all the way from caddies with news from Admiral Collingwood, Cuthbert Collingwood, who's been keeping tabs on the span. at port on the Spanish coast. And this is what Blackwood says to Nelson. He says, Villeneuve has left feral. He left two weeks ago on the 13th of August.
他一路走海路和陆路而来，所以身上沾满了海水和泥土。这个家伙叫亨利·布莱克伍德（Henry Blackwood）。他是“欧律阿罗斯号”（Euryalus）护卫舰的船长。他从加的斯一路赶来，带来了科林伍德（Collingwood）海军上将库斯伯特·科林伍德（Cuthbert Collingwood）的消息，他一直在监视西班牙海岸的西班牙人。这就是布莱克伍德对纳尔逊说的话。他说，维尔纳夫离开了费罗尔。他两周前，也就是8月13日离开的。
He clearly was planning to head towards France, but he was deterred by the site of British cruisers, and he's turned around and gone south. Villeneuve has now taken refuge in the port at Cadiz. He and Gravina have almost 40 ships between them, but they're very short on morale, and they're very short on food and water. and supplies generally. Now, in truth, Villeneuve is pretty much a kind of, is a very demoralized
他显然计划前往法国，但被英国巡洋舰的出现吓阻了，他掉头向南。维尔纳夫现在已经在加的斯港避难。他和格拉维纳两人加起来有近40艘船，但他们士气非常低落，而且非常缺乏食物、水和一般补给。现在，事实上，维尔纳夫几乎是一个非常士气低落的
broken man. Villeneuve has lost faith completely in his emperor's plan, which he always thought was mad. To be fair, the emperor has also lost faith in him, which is also praying on Villeneuve's mind. It is. Now, Nelson doesn't know this, but he does know that Villeneuve cannot stay in caddies for long because there will not be enough supplies. He will have to leave to find supplies. And when he does, You know, this is it. But Dominic also, there's the risk, isn't there? That he might go into the Mediterranean, which would cause chaos, or he might head northwards. So there's opportunity, but there is also risk in Villeneuve and the Spanish breaking out.
破碎的人。维尔纳夫完全失去了对他皇帝计划的信心，他一直认为那是疯狂的。公平地说，皇帝也对他失去了信心，这也让维尔纳夫忧心忡忡。确实如此。现在，纳尔逊不知道这一点，但他确实知道维尔纳夫不能在加的斯待太久，因为补给不足。他必须离开去寻找补给。当他离开时，你知道，就是现在了。但多米尼克，也有风险，不是吗？他可能会进入地中海，那会造成混乱，或者他可能会向北走。所以有机会，但维尔纳夫和西班牙人突围也有风险。
Because there's another Spanish fleet at Cartagena. And if Villeneuve was to link up with them and then to head into the Mediterranean, who knows where he could go? Sardinia, Sicily, Naples, Egypt again. Or what if he then makes for the channel? So Nelson thinks, right, this is my chance. The stakes are very high. If I can annihilate Villeneuve now, then the war is won at sea.
因为在卡塔赫纳还有另一支西班牙舰队。如果维尔纳夫与他们会合，然后进入地中海，谁知道他会去哪里？撒丁岛、西西里岛、那不勒斯、埃及。或者如果他随后前往海峡呢？所以纳尔逊想，好吧，这是我的机会。赌注非常高。如果我现在能消灭维尔纳夫，那么海上战争就赢了。
So within hours, he's jumped into a carriage and he is heading into London. He goes straight to the Admiralty. Then he goes to Downing Street to meet William Pitt and the first Lord, Lord Barham. Nelson says, give me the chance. I want to strike immediately, that will eliminate the threat of invasion, that will give us command of the Mediterranean forever. And as he later told a friend of his, George Rose, who was a confidant of William Pitt, he said, it is annihilation that the country wants, not merely a splendid victory.
所以几个小时内，他跳上一辆马车，前往伦敦。他直接去了海军部。然后他去了唐宁街会见威廉·皮特和第一海军大臣巴勒姆勋爵（Lord Barham）。纳尔逊说，给我机会。我想立即出击，这将消除入侵的威胁，这将使我们永远获得地中海的控制权。正如他后来告诉他的朋友乔治·罗斯（George Rose），他是威廉·皮特的知己，他说，国家需要的是歼灭，而不仅仅是一场辉煌的胜利。
So this is going to be a different kind of battle. The question is, will he get enough ships? Lord Barham says, look, I've only got about 70 ships of the line fit for service to cover the entire globe. But he says, I will back you, go back to Cadiz, take over the victory and take command of the fleet. You can name your own officers. I will send you whatever ships I can. You're probably going to get about 27 in total. And let us hope that is enough. And your instructions, I'll leave it very simple to protect Britain's trade, to prevent the enemy getting to sea. Everything else is up to you. You handle it as you see fit. And I think, don't you,
所以这将是一场不同类型的战斗。问题是，他能得到足够的船只吗？巴勒姆勋爵说，看，我只有大约70艘适合服役的战列舰来覆盖整个地球。但他表示，我会支持你，回到加的斯，接管“胜利号”，指挥舰队。你可以指定你自己的军官。我会尽可能多地派给你船只。你可能会得到总共大约27艘。让我们希望这足够了。你的指令，我会留得很简单：保护英国的贸易，阻止敌人出海。其他一切都由你决定。你认为合适就怎么处理。而且我想，你不觉得吗，
that this is the admiralty and the prime minister and the government buying into this sense of Nelson's destiny, that fate has brought him to this point. And they are kind of going, yes, go for it. Yeah, I think so. You can really sense the mood at this point, this sort of sense that John Sutton described of events hastening towards an inevitable conclusion. And they were all really buying into this. The very next day, it started to rain. This is a sort of fantastic example of the kind of pathetic fallacy. It starts to rain, grey skies. Emma Hamilton has been very downcast by the news that Villeneuve is out. She had hoped that Nelson would be ashore for months, but once again, the clock is ticking. And she writes this letter, doesn't she,
这是海军部、首相和政府在接受纳尔逊的这种命运感，命运将他带到了这一点。他们有点像在说，是的，去吧。是的，我想是这样。你真的能感觉到此时的氛围，约翰·萨格登所描述的那种事件正加速走向不可避免的结局的感觉。他们都真的相信这一点。第二天，开始下雨了。这是一个关于“感伤谬误”的绝佳例子。开始下雨了，灰色的天空。艾玛·汉密尔顿（Emma Hamilton）对维尔纳夫出海的消息感到非常沮丧。她曾希望纳尔逊能在岸上待几个月，但时钟再次滴答作响。她写了这封信，不是吗，
to Lady Kitty Bolton. It seems as though I've had a fortnight's dream and I'm awoke to all the misery of this cruel separation, but what can I do? His powerful arm is of so much consequence to his country, but I cannot say more. My heart is broken. Of course, Nelson doesn't have that much time to think about this because he's thinking about his plan. He is anxious whether he's going to have enough ships. He's thinking about this business about smashing them into fragments. So he's rushing back and forth across London, making all the preparations, getting all the stuff ready, making sure they'll have enough supplies. You know, is he going to link up with the victory, all of this kind of thing.
给基蒂·博尔顿（Kitty Bolton）夫人。似乎我做了一个两周的梦，醒来后发现这种残酷分离的所有痛苦，但我能做什么呢？他强大的手臂对他的国家如此重要，但我不能再多说了。我的心碎了。当然，纳尔逊没有那么多时间去想这些，因为他在想他的计划。他很焦虑是否会有足够的船只。他在想把他们粉碎成碎片这件事。所以他在伦敦奔波，做所有的准备工作，把所有的东西准备好，确保他们有足够的补给。你知道，他会和“胜利号”会合吗，所有这些事情。
Interestingly, there is a sense of fatalism, I think, to Nelson, isn't there? There's a sense that he knows this could be it for him. And I think that that's not just fatalism. I think that's realism, because, as we've been saying, his plan is to form two columns that will drive straight into the French and Spanish lines, which is ripping up the orthodoxy of how you fight a battle. And I'm sure by this point there's no question that he, on victory, is going to be leading one of those two columns, and that means that he will be directly in
有趣的是，纳尔逊有一种宿命论，不是吗？有一种感觉，他知道这对他来说可能是最后一次。我认为这不仅仅是宿命论。我认为那是现实主义，因为正如我们所说，他的计划是组成两列纵队，直接冲入法国和西班牙的阵线，这撕碎了战斗的正统观念。我相信到这个时候，毫无疑问，他将在“胜利号”上带领其中一列纵队，这意味着他将直接处于
the line of fire, because essentially he can't ask his men to risk such a dangerous course of action and not himself be in the forefront of the fighting. So he must think, you know, I'm going to be in more danger in this battle than I've ever been before. And doubtless, he has told Emma this. And that's why she is, or lacrimos would be an unfair word. I mean, that's why she's so devastated at the thought of him leaving. Yeah, I think so. So his last full day is Thursday, the 12th of September. And again, he spends most of it in London.
火线之中，因为本质上他不能要求他的部下冒如此危险的行动，而自己却不身先士卒。所以他一定在想，你知道，我在这场战斗中将比以往任何时候都更危险。毫无疑问，他已经告诉艾玛了。这就是为什么她，或者说“泪流满面”可能是一个不公平的词。我的意思是，这就是为什么她想到他要离开时如此崩溃。是的，我想是这样。所以他最后一个完整的一天是9月12日星期四。同样，他大部分时间都在伦敦度过。
He goes to see Lord Castle Ray at the Colonial Office in Downing Street, very famous incident. Nelson is shown into an ante room to wait for Lord Castle Ray. And another man is waiting there, who's a short man, another short man, who has a very distinctive kind of beaky nose. And this other man makes some sort of polite small talk to Nelson. but Nelson is tired and, of course, he's nervous and he's excited and distracted. And the other man said afterwards, he could not know who I was, but he entered at once into conversation with me, if I can call it conversation, for it was almost all on his side and all about himself, and in really a style so vain and so silly as to surprise and almost
他去唐宁街的殖民地办公室见卡斯尔雷（Castlereagh）勋爵，这是一个非常著名的事件。纳尔逊被带到一个前厅等待卡斯尔雷勋爵。另一个人也在那里等待，他个子不高，又是一个矮个子，有一个非常独特的鹰钩鼻。这另一个人对纳尔逊说了些礼貌的客套话，但纳尔逊很累，当然，他很紧张，很兴奋，心不在焉。那个人后来写道，他不可能知道我是谁，但他立刻与我交谈起来，如果我能称之为交谈的话，因为几乎都是他在说，而且都是关于他自己的，风格确实如此虚荣和愚蠢，以至于令人惊讶，几乎
disgust me. So that's the tone of Lord Minto visiting Merton and seeing all the Nelson memorabilia everywhere. It is. So Nelson just talking about himself, then the other man must have said something that made Nelson think, because Nelson then went out and he had a word with the clerk or the official outside, obviously to find out who this bloat was. And then he came in and was completely transformed because this man is Major General Sir Arthur Wellesley, who is just back from India having been smiting the Maharata Empire and keeping India for the East India Company. and he is, of course, the future Duke of Wellington. And Wellington said, when this Nelson came back in, he was altogether a different man, both in manner and matter.
让我感到厌恶。这就是明托勋爵访问默顿，看到到处都是纳尔逊纪念品时的语气。确实如此。纳尔逊一直在谈论自己，另一个人肯定说了什么让纳尔逊陷入了思考，因为纳尔逊随后走出去，和外面的职员或官员说了几句话，显然是为了打听这个胖子是谁。然后他回来时完全变了个人，因为这个人是阿瑟·韦尔斯利少将，他刚从印度回来，在那儿痛击了马拉塔帝国，为东印度公司守住了印度。他当然就是未来的威灵顿公爵。威灵顿说，当纳尔逊再次回来时，他完全换了个人，无论是在举止还是谈吐上。
What Wellington called his charlatan style had vanished, and he talked about strategy and politics with a good sense and a knowledge that surprised me equally and more agreeably than the first part of our interview had done. He talked like an officer and a statesman. I don't know that I've ever had a conversation that interested me more. Or there you have the two. I mean, obviously this is after the event, so maybe there's a tiny pinch of salt. It plays very well for Wellington, doesn't it?
威灵顿所说的他那种江湖郎中的风格消失了，他谈论战略和政治时表现出的见识和知识，让我感到同样惊讶，而且比我们谈话的第一部分更让我愉快。他谈吐得像个军官，也像个政治家。我不知道我是否曾有过比这更让我感兴趣的谈话。或者说，这就是他们两人。我的意思是，这显然是事后回忆，所以可能要打个小折扣。这对威灵顿来说表现得很好，不是吗？
Because on the one hand, it makes him look good, but it also subtly makes Nelson look a bit of a coxcomb. But that said, this is Nelson to a tea, right? I mean, Nelson would have just talked about himself and being completely spain, self-interested. Well, maybe. I think Nelson has a capacity to take an interest in someone else. He has lapses. I mean, he's often had lapses. Remember the time when he was going from Naples all the way through Vienna and Prague and whatnot?
因为一方面，这让他看起来很不错，但也微妙地让纳尔逊看起来有点像个自负的人。但话虽如此，这确实是典型的纳尔逊，对吧？我的意思是，纳尔逊本来只会谈论自己，完全是自私自利的。嗯，也许吧。我认为纳尔逊有能力去关心别人。他有疏忽的时候。我的意思是，他经常有疏忽。还记得他从那不勒斯一路经过维也纳和布拉格等地的时候吗？
And he wasn't always showing himself to his best side then. Anyway, he's had that meeting with Lord Carcer and his very last meeting is at number 10 Downing Street. And this is his farewell to William Pitt. We don't know what was said, but we do know that Pitt unusually is said to have come down with Nelson and escorted him to his carriage, which was a marked gesture, I think, of affection and respect because Pitt didn't. usually do this. Actually, on his way out of town, there is one last thing. He stops to make sure that the very latest signal book has been sent to the fleet. A good example, actually, of attention to detail. Nelson knows these little things could really make a difference. Do you think he
那时他并没有总是展现出最好的一面。总之，他和卡瑟勋爵见了面，他最后一次会面是在唐宁街10号。这是他向威廉·皮特的告别。我们不知道说了什么，但我们确实知道，皮特一反常态地亲自送纳尔逊下楼，并把他送到了马车上，我认为这是一种明显的关爱和尊重的表示，因为皮特通常不会这样做。事实上，在他离开城镇的路上，还有最后一件事。他停下来确保最新的信号手册已经发送给了舰队。这实际上是一个关注细节的好例子。纳尔逊知道这些小事真的能带来不同。你认为他
already has a zingy slogan in mind? Well, a slogan that actually, as we'll find out, has to be corrected by his signals, lieutenants, because he's trying to send a message for which there's no code. Anyway, that we're jumping ahead. Back he goes to Merton. he's there in time for dinner. But it's a pretty sad occasion. Lord Minto, who is there, said that Emma could not eat and hardly drink and was near swooning. Lord Minto, who's no Emma fan, found all this very over the top and very sort of showy and
脑子里已经有了什么响亮的口号了吗？嗯，一个实际上正如我们将要发现的那样，必须由他的信号中尉来纠正的口号，因为他试图发送一条没有代码的信息。总之，我们扯远了。他回到了默顿。他及时赶回来吃晚饭。但这却是一个相当悲伤的场合。在那里的明托勋爵说，艾玛几乎吃不下东西，也喝不下水，几乎要昏厥过去。明托勋爵，他并不是艾玛的粉丝，觉得这一切非常夸张，非常做作，
performative. So Emma is clearly very, very upset. You know, Nelson is going away and maybe this will be for the last time. He will have shared the odds with her. I mean, you know, I don't think it's performative at all. I think if you're in love with someone and he's going off and likely to die, I think you're allowed the occasional tear. Oh, you're a soft-hearted.
表演性很强。所以艾玛显然非常非常难过。你知道，纳尔逊要走了，也许这是最后一次了。他会和她分享这些遭遇。我的意思是，你知道，我不认为这是表演。我认为如果你爱一个人，而他要离开，很可能会死，我想你是可以偶尔流泪的。哦，你真是个心软的人。
So the next day is Friday the 13th of September. It's the last day of their lives together. It's a cloudy, windy day and they are stuck inside and Merton. Now, it may be today that there's a sort of celebrated incidents. They took communion together, Nelson and Emma, and they exchanged gold rings in what they called a private sacrament. So, myographers often describe this as kind of unofficial betrothal or marriage ceremony. Nelson, of course, is married already.
所以第二天是9月13日，星期五。这是他们在一起生活的最后一天。那是一个多云、有风的日子，他们被困在默顿的室内。现在，可能就是今天发生了某种著名的事件。纳尔逊和艾玛一起领了圣餐，他们交换了金戒指，举行了他们所谓的私人圣礼。所以，传记作者经常把这描述为一种非正式的订婚或结婚仪式。当然，纳尔逊已经结婚了。
Tafani, his ring, which I think recently came up for auction. It was mounted with a large H and was actually engraved with the date the 13th of September, probably afterward, well, it must have been afterwards, I guess, which suggests that they did something because they know, as you've said, this could be it. This could be the last time they ever see each other. You know, it's a very humdrum day. Nelson's doing a lot of chores. he's making a lot of arrangements to pay, you know, bills, bills for prints, no doubt of himself
塔法尼，他的戒指，我想最近出现在拍卖会上。它镶嵌着一个大大的H，实际上还刻着9月13日的日期，可能是在那之后，嗯，我想肯定是在那之后，这表明他们确实做了些什么，因为他们知道，正如你所说，这可能是最后一次了。这可能是他们最后一次见到对方。你知道，这是非常平淡的一天。纳尔逊在做很多杂事。他做了很多安排来支付，你知道，账单，毫无疑问是他自己的印刷品账单，
and wine and whatnot and architect's bills. The coach has been ordered for 10 o'clock that evening to take him down to the coast, to the victory. Night falls, the hour approaches, the scene that you described earlier, he goes up to Horatia to say goodbye. The coach is loaded. Emma is in tears. She won't come outside. Nelson comes back in four times from the coach.
还有酒之类的账单，以及建筑师的账单。马车已经预定在当天晚上10点来接他去海岸，去胜利号。夜幕降临，时间临近，你之前描述的那个场景，他上楼去和霍拉蒂亚告别。马车装好了。艾玛泪流满面。她不肯出来。纳尔逊从马车上回来四次。
And finally, he does this thing where he kneels and asks God his blessing. And he says these lines that, Tom, you find very moving. If there were more Emmas, there would be more Nelson's and all of this. But that's not the last exchange, actually. The very last exchange is with his brother-in-law, George Matcham, and his marriage to Nelson's sister. And Nelson says to George, I'm actually really sorry that I haven't done more for our family. You know, I should have done more, made more money. Maybe this time I'll get some prize money.
最后，他做了这件事，他跪下来祈求上帝的保佑。他说了这些台词，汤姆，你觉得非常感人。如果多一些艾玛，就会多一些纳尔逊，诸如此类。但那实际上并不是最后的交流。最后的交流是与他的姐夫乔治·马查姆，以及他与纳尔逊姐姐的婚姻。纳尔逊对乔治说，我其实真的很抱歉，我没有为我们的家庭做更多的事情。你知道，我本应该做更多，赚更多的钱。也许这次我会得到一些奖金。
And George says to him, we want for nothing all that matters to us is that you're safe and away nelson goes into the night and then he writes that moving journal entry that you read out where he's again thinking about his own death if it's god's good providence to cut short my days on earth i bow with the greatest submission and he hopes that god will protect those so dear to me that i leave behind and as we'll see next time that's a running theme even in extremists before the battle and after the battle Nelson is thinking about those people that he's left behind. At six o'clock the following morning, his carriage arrives at the George Inn at Portsmouth.
乔治对他说，我们什么都不缺，我们唯一在乎的是你平安无事。纳尔逊走进夜色中，然后他写下了你读到的那篇感人的日记，他在那里再次思考自己的死亡：如果上帝的仁慈要缩短我在世上的日子，我将以最大的顺从低头。他希望上帝能保护那些我留下的、我如此珍视的人。正如我们下次将看到的，即使在战斗前和战斗后的极端情况下，这也是一个贯穿始终的主题，纳尔逊一直在想着那些他留下的人。第二天早上六点，他的马车抵达了朴茨茅斯的乔治旅馆。
Nelson writes a note to Emma. My dearest and most beloved of women, Emma, Nelson's Emma, I arrived here. Victories at St. Helens, if possible, I shall be away at sea this day. God protect you and my dear Horatia. Portsmouth is a port preparing for war. Carts and wagons everywhere, loads of people. I mean, this is a great dockyard. It's one of the great motors of Britain's war effort.
纳尔逊给艾玛写了一张便条。我最亲爱、最深爱的女人，艾玛，纳尔逊的艾玛，我到了这里。胜利号在圣海伦斯，如果可能的话，我今天就要出海了。上帝保佑你和我亲爱的霍拉蒂亚。朴茨茅斯是一个正在为战争做准备的港口。到处都是马车和货车，到处都是人。我的意思是，这是一个伟大的造船厂。它是英国战争努力的伟大引擎之一。
And Nelson, actually, before he leaves, this is a lovely detail. He has the time to visit a new manufacturing that is almost ready to kind of go online at Portsmouth, which is this block mills, powered by steam. It's the most advanced factory on earth. It has been designed by a French exile called Mark Isambard Brunel. And it has machines basically to create these blocks, these kind of blocks. I don't quite understand what these blocks do. They're kind of to do with pulleys, aren't they? Yeah, pulleys and ropes.
纳尔逊，实际上，在他离开之前，这是一个可爱的细节。他有时间参观一个几乎准备好在朴茨茅斯投入使用的制造厂，这就是滑轮厂，由蒸汽驱动。它是地球上最先进的工厂。它是由一位名叫马克·伊桑巴德·布鲁内尔的法国流亡者设计的。它基本上有机器来制造这些滑轮，这些种类的滑轮。我不太明白这些滑轮是做什么的。它们是和滑轮有关的，对吧？是的，滑轮和绳索。
Yeah, exactly. So brilliant rope work. And the amazing detail that I remember from our previous series is that there was machinery operating in Portsmouth when Nelson left on Victory that was still operating in 1982 when the Falklands Task Force left. I mean, it's incredible. That's a crazy detail, isn't it? So he goes back to the Georgian after that.
是的，完全正确。所以是出色的绳索工作。我从我们之前的系列中记得的一个惊人的细节是，当纳尔逊离开胜利号时，朴茨茅斯有机器在运行，直到1982年福克兰特遣部队离开时，这些机器还在运行。我的意思是，这太不可思议了。那是一个疯狂的细节，不是吗？所以在那之后他回到了乔治旅馆。
He goes through a back door to avoid the crowds, and he's going to leave from the beach by the bathing machines. So a nice Emma-related touch there. It is. It's not the normal place. He's trying to escape the crowds, but actually there are hundreds of people waiting. And as he comes down to the boarding point,
他从后门走以避开人群，他要从沐浴车旁边的海滩离开。所以那里有一个与艾玛相关的温馨细节。确实是。这不是通常的地方。他试图逃避人群，但实际上有数百人在等待。当他走到登船点时，
there are people kneeling on the ground. There are people cheering. There are people trying to touch his coat. Some people are in tears. And as his boat pushes away towards the victory, they give him three cheers, and he waves his hat in farewell. And then very famously, Nelson murmurs,
有人跪在地上。有人在欢呼。有人试图触摸他的外套。有些人泪流满面。当他的小船向胜利号驶去时，他们为他欢呼三次，他挥动帽子告别。然后非常著名的是，纳尔逊喃喃自语，
I had their hussars before. I have their hearts now. And by 1130, he is on the victory and his last voyage begins. Unbelievable drama. My heart is beating so fast that I need to go and calm down. But we will be back in a few minutes to continue the story of Nelson's journey to Trafalgar. This episode is sponsored by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. History's most fascinating questions don't have simple answers. Meet Claude, the AI built for
我以前拥有过他们的轻骑兵。我现在拥有了他们的心。到11点30分，他在胜利号上，他的最后一次航行开始了。令人难以置信的戏剧性。我的心跳得太快了，我需要去冷静一下。但我们几分钟后会回来，继续讲述纳尔逊前往特拉法尔加的故事。本集由Anthropic赞助，这是Claude背后的团队。历史上最迷人的问题没有简单的答案。认识一下Claude，这是为
deep thinking. Whether you're tracing how ideas moved across empires or exploring why certain patterns repeat, Claude works through historical complexity with you, researching with citations and connecting threads across centuries. Try Claude for free at clod.aI slash rest is history. and see why the world's best problem solvers choose Claude as their thinking partner. This episode is brought to you by Peloton. A new era of fitness is here. Introducing the new Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus,
深度思考而构建的AI。无论你是追踪思想如何在帝国间移动，还是探索为什么某些模式会重复，Claude都会与你一起研究历史的复杂性，通过引用进行研究，并连接跨越几个世纪的线索。在clod.aI/restishistory免费试用Claude，看看为什么世界上最优秀的解决问题者选择Claude作为他们的思考伙伴。本集由Peloton为您带来。健身的新时代已经到来。隆重推出全新的Peloton交叉训练Tread Plus，
powered by Peloton IQ. Built for breakthroughs with personalized workout plans, real-time insights, and endless ways to move. Lift with confidence. While Peloton IQ counts reps, corrects form, and tracks your progress. Let yourself run, lift, flow, and go.
由Peloton IQ提供支持。为突破而生，拥有个性化的锻炼计划、实时见解和无穷无尽的运动方式。自信地举重。当Peloton IQ计算次数、纠正姿势并跟踪你的进度时。让自己奔跑、举重、流动并前进。
Explore the new Peloton Cross-Training Treadplus at OnePeloton.C.A. It's the matchat or the three ensemble Ciceroa of Cephora of FET that I just niche who energize over? Mm, it's the ensemble. The format standard
在OnePeloton.C.A探索全新的Peloton交叉训练Treadplus。是matchat还是三个合奏Ciceroa of Cephora of FET，我只是niche谁充满活力？嗯，是合奏。格式标准
and mini-regruped, what abem? And the embellage, too beau, who is practically pre-a-donned. And I know I'd they'd like
和迷你重组，什么abem？还有embellage，太漂亮了，几乎是预先穿好的。我知道他们喜欢
Summer Fridays and Rare Beauty by by Selena Gomez. I'm just the most ensemble, the Cado of the Fettos Cepora.
Summer Fridays和Rare Beauty by Selena Gomez。我只是最合奏，Cado of the Fettos Cepora。
Summer Fridays, Rare Beauty, Way, Cifora Collection, Repart of VIT. Procurry you Corma standard and mini regrouped for
Summer Fridays, Rare Beauty, Way, Cifora Collection, Repart of VIT。为你采购Corma标准和迷你重组，为了
a better quality of price. In line on C4A. or in magazine. Hello,
更好的价格质量。在线在C4A上。或在杂志中。你好，
everyone. Welcome back. It is Saturday the 14th of September 1805. Horatio Nelson has been
大家好。欢迎回来。今天是1805年9月14日，星期六。霍拉蒂奥·纳尔逊已经
reunited with HMS Victory and he is preparing to sail south to face the combined fleet,
与胜利号HMS Victory重聚，他正准备向南航行，去面对联合舰队，
the French and Spanish ships. And Dominic he has exactly one month and one week left to live. So, the victory. The victory, and with which Nelson is forever associated, is an excellent, Nick. It is, you know, how old is the victory at this point?
法国和西班牙的船只。多米尼克，他只剩下整整一个月零一周的生命了。所以，胜利号。胜利号，纳尔逊永远与它联系在一起，是一个极好的昵称。确实是，你知道，胜利号此时有多老了？
It's about 40 years, I think. Yeah, 40 years old. It was named after the victories in the seven years war, wasn't it? It's had a full refit while he's been ashore. The rigging's been repaired, the deck's been scrubbed. The guns have been taken out and checked and run in again. The crew are pretty knackard. They haven't had a break, unlike Nelson. And Hardy, he's been flogging away who sneaks up behind you. With his big feet and his stooped shoulders. Yeah, he is absolutely exhausted. I mean, people when they saw him said he looked like he'd aged 20 years in one year. And he already looked quite old. In their favor, they are very healthy. So Hardy has looked after their health as Nelson has. They're tired, but they are fit and they
我想大约40年了。是的，40岁了。它是以七年战争中的胜利命名的，不是吗？在他上岸期间，它进行了全面的改装。索具已经修理，甲板已经擦洗。大炮已经被拆除、检查并重新安装。船员们相当疲惫。他们没有休息，不像纳尔逊。还有哈迪，他一直在努力工作，那个在你身后悄悄出现的人。带着他那双大脚和弯曲的肩膀。是的，他绝对精疲力竭。我的意思是，人们看到他时说，他看起来好像一年老了20岁。而且他本来就看起来相当老了。对他们有利的是，他们非常健康。所以哈迪像纳尔逊一样照顾了他们的健康。他们很累，但他们很健康，而且他们
know they're, you know, as we would discover, they are the best fighting men anywhere in the world. They know exactly what their goal is. And pumped by having Nelson. Of course, they're delighted to see him. So now they sail south, banned for Spain. They make quite slow progress because it's foggy and windy, not windy in a good way. Nelson all the time, as so often is writing to Emma, entreating her to cheer up and saying, you know, we can look forward to many, many happy years and to be surrounded by our children and our children's children. As I said, they move quite slowly. They only glimpse Lisbon on the 25th of September
知道他们的，你知道，正如我们将要发现的那样，他们是世界上最好的战斗人员。他们确切地知道他们的目标是什么。而且因为有纳尔逊而充满动力。当然，他们很高兴见到他。所以现在他们向南航行，前往西班牙。他们的进展相当缓慢，因为有雾且有风，不是那种好的风。纳尔逊一直像往常一样给艾玛写信，恳求她振作起来，说，你知道，我们可以期待许多许多幸福的岁月，并被我们的孩子和孙子们环绕。正如我所说，他们移动得相当缓慢。他们直到9月25日才瞥见里斯本，
11 days later and they only reach the fleet of Cadiz three days after that. When they get there there is this tremendous sense of excitement among the captains in Cadiz. So many of these captains are not familiar to Nelson. These are not the band of brothers from the Nile.
11天后，他们三天后才到达加的斯的舰队。当他们到达那里时，加的斯的船长们之间有一种巨大的兴奋感。这些船长中有很多纳尔逊并不熟悉。这些不是尼罗河上的兄弟连。
These are often younger, much more inexperienced men. Only five of them have commanded a ship of the Lion in battle before. Some of these are well-known names. You know, Thomas Hardy, Thomas Fremantle, Edward Berry, Vice Admiral Cuthbert Collingwood, of course, Nelson's old friend from when they were very young.
这些通常是更年轻、经验不足的人。只有五个人以前指挥过战列舰。其中一些是众所周知的名字。你知道，托马斯·哈迪、托马斯·弗里曼特尔、爱德华·贝里、副海军上将库斯伯特·科林伍德，当然，纳尔逊从他们很年轻时起的老朋友。
Collingwood, I mean, we talked about him in ironically the episode about History's Grace's dogs. We did. His beloved dog bounce. Yeah. So Collingwood, who's been in charge of the fleet, he's a sort of, he's a really kind of kindly and decent man, quite shy and retiring, but doesn't have Nelson's star quality, does he?
科林伍德，我的意思是，我们在关于历史上的优雅狗的那一集中讽刺地谈到了他。我们确实谈到了。他心爱的狗Bounce。是的。所以科林伍德，他一直负责舰队，他是一个，他真的是一个非常和蔼可亲的人，相当害羞和内向，但没有纳尔逊的明星气质，对吧？
He loves nothing more than his Northumberland. garden. He does and planting oak trees there. But I mean, Nelson doesn't know many of the captains, but of course the captains know all about Nelson. And for them, it's like the arrival of a rock star. Very exciting moment. So Saturday the 28th of September that he reaches the fleet and he immediately says, let's pull back the fleet, but you're over the horizon, we'll leave the frigates to watch cadiz. We don't want to blockade it too closely because we want Villeneuve to come out. But having the frigates there, he's learnt the lesson from when the French fleet had escaped from Toulon. His blockade there had existed to encourage the French
他最喜欢的就是他的诺森伯兰花园。他确实喜欢，并在那里种植橡树。但我的意思是，纳尔逊并不认识很多船长，但当然船长们对纳尔逊了如指掌。对他们来说，这就像摇滚明星的到来。非常激动人心的时刻。所以9月28日星期六，他到达了舰队，他立即说，让我们撤回舰队，但你们在地平线上，我们将留下护卫舰监视加的斯。我们不想封锁得太紧，因为我们想让维尔纳夫出来。但有了护卫舰在那里，他吸取了法国舰队从土伦逃脱时的教训。他在那里的封锁是为了鼓励法国人
to come out, but it had left a gap that they had then utilised it. He's not going to let that happen now. No. So they're waiting for the French, but the weather is very fine, sort of dry, hazy, there's no wind. The French and the Spanish are not going to move in this kind of weather. The next day, the Sunday is Nelson's 47th birthday. He has exactly. 22 days to live. And that Sunday afternoon, he starts the process of building team spirit and camaraderie among the captains. He invites them in batches to dinner aboard the victory. And because they're younger and because they're not as experienced, he is very keen to make them feel part of the story, part of the planning and whatnot. So he will gather them. This is one of the
出来，但它留下了一个缺口，他们随后利用了它。他现在不会让这种情况发生。不。所以他们在等法国人，但天气非常好，干燥、朦胧，没有风。法国人和西班牙人在这种天气下是不会动的。第二天，星期天是纳尔逊的47岁生日。他还有整整22天可活。那个星期天下午，他开始了在船长们中间建立团队精神和同志情谊的过程。他分批邀请他们到胜利号上共进晚餐。因为他们更年轻，因为他们经验不足，他非常热衷于让他们感到自己是故事的一部分，是计划的一部分等等。所以他会召集他们。这是其中之一
things that makes him a brilliant leader, a brilliant leader and a model of leadership. He will gather of them in his great cabin, you know, which you can visit today in Portsmouth on the victory, they will sit around this big mahogany table. They will have dinner off silver plate and wine and wine glasses and so on. It's very convivial and he makes them feel valued. It makes them feel seen to use today's kind of jargon. Yeah, there's such kind of wonderful testimony. So, Captain Fremantle, we dined with Lord Nelson, the juniors and I never passed a pleasant a day. I stand with him until eight at night. He would not let me leave him before. And then there's another captain George Duff, who never met Nelson and writes to his wife.
让他成为杰出领导者的事情，杰出的领导者和领导力的典范。他会把他们召集在他的大船舱里，你知道，你今天可以在朴茨茅斯的胜利号上参观，他们会坐在那张巨大的红木桌子旁。他们会用银盘子和酒杯吃晚餐等等。非常欢乐，他让他们感到被重视。用今天的术语来说，这让他们感到被看见了。是的，有这样美妙的见证。所以，弗里曼特尔船长，我们和纳尔逊勋爵共进晚餐，那些后辈们，我从未度过如此愉快的一天。我和他待到晚上八点。他不想让我离开他。然后还有另一位船长乔治·达夫，他从未见过纳尔逊，写信给他的妻子。
I dined with his lordship yesterday and had a very merry dinner. He is certainly the pleasant as the Admiral I ever served under. He is so good and pleasant a man that we all wish to do what he likes without any kind of orders. And you get there the sense of the star quality, he's writing to his wife saying, I've met Nelson, but also, you know, he's great. He puts you with ease, and he makes you feel like you are part of a band of brothers. And this is exactly Nelson's plan. He wants them to feel calm and confident.
我昨天和勋爵共进晚餐，吃了一顿非常愉快的晚餐。他无疑是我服役过的最令人愉快的海军上将。他是一个如此善良和愉快的人，以至于我们都希望在没有任何命令的情况下做他喜欢做的事。你从那里感受到了明星气质，他写信给他的妻子说，我见到了纳尔逊，而且，你知道，他很棒。他让你感到轻松，他让你觉得你是兄弟连的一员。这正是纳尔逊的计划。他希望他们感到冷静和自信。
He knows that they will be outnumbered. So they have to completely believe in what they are doing. And what he wants to explain in particular is this thing that he calls the Nelson Touch, which is a strategy that is based on speed and aggression, striking really fast and hard under full sail, get in close for this pell-mell battle, and annihilate the French and the Spanish and settle the issue at sea. for good. It is annihilation that the country wants, not merely a splendid victory. And of course, the parallel there is with Napoleon on land. That's Napoleon strategy. And in that sense, Nelson is the kind of the British Napoleon. You know, the comparison with Napoleon is an
他知道他们的人数会处于劣势。所以他们必须完全相信他们正在做的事情。他特别想解释的是他称之为“纳尔逊之触”的东西，这是一种基于速度和侵略性的战略，在全帆下非常快速和猛烈地打击，靠近进行这种混战，并彻底消灭法国人和西班牙人，一劳永逸地解决海上的问题。国家想要的是歼灭，而不仅仅是一场辉煌的胜利。当然，这里的相似之处在于拿破仑在陆地上。那是拿破仑的战略。从这个意义上说，纳尔逊是英国的拿破仑。你知道，与拿破仑的比较是一个
interesting one because both of them inspire this extraordinary affection and respect among their closest officers. Nelson described, and I don't think he's exaggerating, he wrote to Emma, he said, when I explained to them my plan, the Nelson touch, it was like an electric shock. Some shed tears, all approved. It was new. It was singular. It was simple. I think part of this is Nelson's style quality, but also you mentioned earlier, this is becoming part of the culture of the Navy. The Royal Navy over the last sort of 10, 20 years, has developed this new ethos. No more of the sort of stately minuettes. You get in and you absolutely go for total destruction of the enemy and that's something new in naval history. And what he's saying to his captains is
有趣的比较，因为他们两人都在他们最亲密的军官中激发了这种非凡的爱戴和尊重。纳尔逊描述说，我不认为他在夸大其词，他写信给艾玛，他说，当我向他们解释我的计划，“纳尔逊之触”时，就像电击一样。有些人流下了眼泪，所有人都表示赞同。它是新的。它是独特的。它是简单的。我认为这部分是纳尔逊的明星气质，但也如你之前提到的，这正在成为海军文化的一部分。皇家海军在过去大约10、20年里，发展出了这种新的精神。不再有那种庄严的小步舞曲。你进入并绝对追求敌人的彻底毁灭，这在海军史上是新的。他对他的船长们说的是
you are the best and your men are the best and my strategy reflects that. So it's very, very complementary to them. But will they get the battle? September becomes October and still they wait. Nelson's fleet has now been reinforced. It's grown to 33 ships of the line. Most of them are two-decker 74s, the kind of standard, you know, battleship, warship of the day. And there are another four frigates. And these ships, to remind people, these are effectively huge floating gun platforms. They are killing machines. I mean, the firepower available to Nelson is massively in excess of, say, the firepower
你们是最好的，你们的人也是最好的，我的战略反映了这一点。所以这对他们来说是非常赞美的。但他们能打上仗吗？九月变成了十月，他们还在等待。纳尔逊的舰队现在得到了加强。它增加到了33艘战列舰。大多数是双层甲板的74炮舰，那种标准的，你知道，战列舰，当时的军舰。还有另外四艘护卫舰。这些船，提醒人们，实际上是巨大的浮动火炮平台。它们是杀人机器。我的意思是，纳尔逊拥有的火力远远超过，比如说，火力
that Wellington will have at Waterloo, I mean, by an enormous quantity. And just a word on the men that he's commanding, 20,000 sailors and marines. And it's not a kind of modern contrivance to point out, this is a genuinely multinational kind of force. So on the victory, for example, there are Englishmen, but they're also Scots, Irish. There are 22 Americans, nine men from the West Indies, Maltese, there's a Russian, there's an African. There are even three Frenchmen. Yeah, and you see that famously on the reliefs at the foot of Nelson's column in Trafalgar Square, very pointedly illustrated. Yes, an African guy who people identified as George Ryan.
威灵顿在滑铁卢拥有的火力，我的意思是，数量巨大。关于他指挥的人，2万名水手和海军陆战队。指出这一点并不是一种现代的虚构，这确实是一支真正的多国部队。所以以胜利号为例，有英国人，但也有苏格兰人、爱尔兰人。有22名美国人，9名来自西印度群岛的人，马耳他人，有一个俄罗斯人，有一个非洲人。甚至有三个法国人。是的，你在特拉法尔加广场纳尔逊纪念柱底部的浮雕上著名地看到了这一点，非常明确地说明了。是的，一个被人们认定为乔治·瑞安的非洲人。
I might talk about him in the next episode. So for Nelson, keeping all these different men fit and healthy is the absolute priority. So actually what he's doing in all this, all this time, day after day, is the kind of, you know, the bureaucratic work that he'd been doing during the blockade. He's getting supplies. He's organizing fresh food and water. He's organizing drills. He's doing all this kind of thing. He sends Jane Austen's brother off to get oranges. That's right. And so he then misses the battle and is devastated. But of course, Dominic, what he's also doing is moping over Emma and writing poetry. Can I read a poem? I think everyone would love that. So this is his last love poem to Emma. No calm at sea, this heart shall know, while far from the midst lengthening hours of absence and of woe, I gaze in sorrow were the boundless deep,
我可能会在下一集中谈论他。所以对纳尔逊来说，保持所有这些不同的人健康和强壮是绝对的优先事项。所以实际上他在所有这些时间里所做的事情，日复一日，就是那种，你知道，他在封锁期间一直在做的官僚工作。他在获取补给。他在组织新鲜的食物和水。他在组织演习。他在做所有这些事情。他派简·奥斯汀的兄弟去买橘子。没错。然后他错过了战斗，感到非常沮丧。但当然，多米尼克，他还在做的事情是为艾玛闷闷不乐并写诗。我可以读一首诗吗？我想每个人都会喜欢的。所以这是他给艾玛的最后一首情诗。海上无宁静，此心当知，远离那漫长的缺席与悲伤的时刻，我忧伤地凝视着无边的大海，
with eyes which, were they not ashamed, would weep. I think that's very good. I think it's solid. I think it's pretty good. Yeah, I agree with you. I definitely agree with you. And while he's doing this, his captains are also doing a very nice thing, something will be very familiar to anyone who's visited H.
用那双如果不感到羞愧就会流泪的眼睛。我认为这非常好。我认为它很扎实。我认为它相当不错。是的，我同意你的看法。我绝对同意你的看法。当他这样做时，他的船长们也在做一件非常好的事情，任何参观过H的人都会非常熟悉的事情。
victory at Portsmouth, and that is they are painting their ships black and yellow in imitation of the colour scheme that Nelson preferred. I've read different things from his biographers. Some say he ordered it, and others, in their gesture that I prefer, say that his captains were motivated to do it voluntarily because they wanted to, as Captain Duff put it, to paint their ships, a la Nelson. Kind of swarm of hornets as well. Yeah, this sense of being a team.
朴茨茅斯的胜利号，那就是他们正在把他们的船漆成黑色和黄色，以模仿纳尔逊喜欢的配色方案。我从他的传记作者那里读到过不同的东西。有些人说他下令这样做，而另一些人，在我更喜欢的姿态中，说他的船长们是自愿这样做的，因为他们想，正如达夫船长所说，把他们的船漆成“纳尔逊风格”。也像一群大黄蜂。是的，这种作为一个团队的感觉。
in pursuit of a common goal. I like that. Now, still, the combined fleet don't come out. On the 2nd of October, Nelson sent a squadron under Sir Thomas Louis to collect food and water from Gibraltar and North Africa. So now his numbers are down by six, from 33 to 27, six fewer, as it turns out, than the combined fleet. Still he waits. On the 9th of October, he sends Collingwood his final battle plan.
追求一个共同的目标。我喜欢那样。现在，联合舰队仍然没有出来。10月2日，纳尔逊派出一支由托马斯·路易斯爵士率领的中队去从直布罗陀和北非收集食物和水。所以现在他的数量减少了6艘，从33艘减少到27艘，事实证明比联合舰队少了6艘。他还在等待。10月9日，他把最终的作战计划发给了科林伍德。
And he says, I'm sending you this so you know exactly what I want to do, and so that you can use your own initiative to carry out my instructions according to the general plan. He says, we can, my dear Cole, have no little jealousies. We can only have one great object in view, that of annihilating our enemies and getting a glorious peace for our country. No man has more confidence in another than I have in you, and no man will render your services more justice than your very old friend, Nelson and Bronte. It's Nelson reaching out to his kind of deputy.
他说，我把这个发给你是为了让你确切地知道我想做什么，这样你就可以利用你自己的主动性，根据总体计划执行我的指示。他说，我亲爱的科尔，我们不能有小嫉妒。我们只能有一个伟大的目标，那就是消灭我们的敌人，为我们的国家争取光荣的和平。没有人比我更信任另一个人，也没有人会比你更公正地对待你的服务，你非常老的朋友，纳尔逊和布朗特。这是纳尔逊在向他的副手伸出援手。
So Nelson explains the plan. Basically, there's two columns are going to attack and strike the enemy line head on. Nelson, leading one in the victory, Collingwood leading the other in the royal sovereign. Now, what is unusual about this is admirals usually like to keep their ships in the centre, but Nelson says, no, I will lead from the front. We won't fire until we're really close. But, I mean, they won't be able to, will they? That's the key thing.
所以纳尔逊解释了这个计划。基本上，两列纵队将进攻并正面冲击敌人的防线。纳尔逊在胜利号上带领一列，科林伍德在皇家君主号上带领另一列。现在，这不同寻常之处在于海军上将通常喜欢把他们的船保持在中心，但纳尔逊说，不，我将从前面领导。我们直到非常近的时候才会开火。但是，我的意思是，他们将无法做到，对吧？这是关键所在。
Because the reason that you have this minuet is that the ship can only fire at an angle. So if you're going straight at a line, you can't actually fire until you've broken through past the line. Exactly. But the danger is that if their side onto you, they will be blasting and blasting you before you can turn to get into position to repay the complement, as it were. And so Nelson's presentiments of death, I think, are entirely natural. I mean, that's what makes it so dangerous. Yes, exactly. However, still the combined fleet does not move.
因为你之所以有这种小步舞曲的原因是船只能以一定角度开火。所以如果你直冲一条线，你实际上无法开火，直到你突破了那条线。完全正确。但危险在于，如果他们侧面对着你，他们会在你转弯进入位置以回敬对方之前，不断地轰炸你。所以纳尔逊对死亡的预感，我认为是完全自然的。我的意思是，这就是它如此危险的原因。是的，完全正确。然而，联合舰队仍然没有移动。
Still, Nelson waits, and more than two weeks go by, and by about Friday the 18th, he's beginning to wonder if the combined fleet is ever going to come out at all. That day, the Friday, the wind off-cat is changed, and Nelson in his journal wrote, Fine weather, wind easterly. The enemy cannot have finer weather to set sail. Colleen would send him a message that day saying, surely the combined fleet will move now. but the day passes and no news comes. And then the next morning, Saturday the 19th of October, 9 o'clock in the morning, Nelson is writing a letter to Collingwood,
纳尔逊仍然在等待，两周多过去了，到18日星期五左右，他开始怀疑联合舰队是否还会出来。那天，星期五，加的斯外的风向变了，纳尔逊在日记中写道，天气晴朗，东风。敌人不可能有更好的天气起航了。科林伍德那天给他发了一条信息说，联合舰队现在肯定会移动了。但这一天过去了，没有消息传来。然后第二天早上，10月19日星期六，早上9点，纳尔逊正在给科林伍德写信，
Dear Cole, to invite him for dinner. And bounce on the dog. What a beautiful day. Will you be tempted out of your ship? If you will, hoist the ascent and victory's pendants. And then just a moment after Nelson has written that letter, there comes a signal from the frigate. And Nelson knows what that means.
亲爱的科尔，邀请他共进晚餐。还有那只狗Bounce。多么美好的一天。你会受到诱惑离开你的船吗？如果你愿意，升起信号旗和胜利号的三角旗。就在纳尔逊写完那封信后不久，护卫舰传来了一个信号。纳尔逊知道那意味着什么。
Because 50 miles east in the port of Cadiz, Villeneuve's nerve at last has cracked. And the French and the Spanish are going to put to sea. So, Dominic, what has been happening in Cadiz? Because you said that they can't really stay there because they didn't really have the supplies. I suppose there's also the risk of disease. If they don't have enough fruit, there's scurvy and all that kind of thing. And they're ravaged by yellow fever. Which they brought back from the Caribbean.
因为在50英里外的加的斯港，维尔纳夫的神经终于崩溃了。法国人和西班牙人要出海了。所以，多米尼克，加的斯发生了什么？因为你说他们不能真的待在那里，因为他们没有足够的补给。我想还有疾病的风险。如果他们没有足够的水果，就会有坏血病之类的东西。而且他们受到黄热病的蹂躏。他们从加勒比海带回来的。
Yes. Villeneuve has been basically skulking in Cadiz in a right misery. About half of his men were not sailors, they are infantrymen, and they had been supplemented by slaves from France's Caribbean colonies. Villeneuve was very disparaging about the quality of his own men. He said they were herdsmen and beggars. Well, he is an aristocrat. And a French aristocrat at that, the most aristocratic of all aristocrats.
是的。维尔纳夫基本上一直躲在加的斯，处于一种真正的痛苦中。他大约一半的人不是水手，他们是步兵，而且他们得到了来自法国加勒比殖民地的奴隶的补充。维尔纳夫对他自己人的素质非常贬低。他说他们是牧民和乞丐。嗯，他是一位贵族。而且是一位法国贵族，所有贵族中最贵族的。
So in early October, he'd received orders from the Emperor from Napoleon, telling him to break out of Cadiz and head east towards. Italy, because there Bonaparte was planning a new offensive against Naples. Now, at first, Villeneuve completely ignored his orders. He thought it's absolutely madness to try to break out of Cadiz with Nelson just there, waiting for us. Better to try to sneak out in bad weather, or to wait for the British to lose interest and to divide their fleet.
所以10月初，他收到了皇帝拿破仑的命令，告诉他突破加的斯，向东前往意大利，因为波拿巴在那里计划对那不勒斯进行新的进攻。现在，起初，维尔纳夫完全无视了他的命令。他认为试图在纳尔逊就在那里等待我们的情况下突破加的斯绝对是疯狂的。最好尝试在恶劣天气下溜走，或者等待英国人失去兴趣并分散他们的舰队。
But then a week later, Villeneuve had heard two items of news that changed his mind. First of all, he heard this news that Nelson had sent Thomas Louis off to get supplies. the combined fleet had a numerical advantage. But secondly, and even more importantly, I think, he was told that Napoleon was about to sack him, that his replacement, in fact, was already en route to Cadiz, which is true. And Villeneuve knew that armchair critics in Paris were saying that he was a coward,
但一周后，维尔纳夫听到了两条改变他想法的消息。首先，他听到了纳尔逊派托马斯·路易斯去获取补给的消息。联合舰队在数量上占有优势。但其次，我认为更重要的是，他被告知拿破仑即将解雇他，事实上，他的继任者已经在前往加的斯的路上，这是真的。维尔纳夫知道巴黎的扶手椅批评家们在说他是个懦夫，
that he'd run away at the Battle of the Nile, and he didn't have the guts to face Nelson. And this is really his last chance, if he's going to be sacked to clear his name and to go down fighting, And he says to his officers, they will see if I know how to fight. Because Villeneuve, to be clear, I don't think Villeneuve is a coward. I don't think he's a bad commander. I think he's actually a pretty honorable and in many ways,
他在尼罗河战役中逃跑了，他没有胆量面对纳尔逊。如果他要被解雇，这是他洗清名声并战死沙场的最后机会。他对他的军官们说，他们会看看我是否知道如何战斗。因为维尔纳夫，要明确一点，我不认为维尔纳夫是个懦夫。我不认为他是个糟糕的指挥官。我认为他实际上是一个相当光荣的，在许多方面，
and quite an impressive and admirable man. And I think wanting to put to sea, you know, wanting to, you know, roll the dice and see if he can clear his name, an understandable and admirable thing to do. So on the 18th of October, he said to Gravina, this Spanish counterpart, with whom he actually got on pretty well. He said, look, we're going to put to sea the way we will deal with Nelson if he catches up with us. Because we've got so many infantrymen, we will turn this into a land battle.
而且是一个相当令人印象深刻和令人钦佩的人。我认为想要出海，你知道，想要，你知道，掷骰子看看他是否能洗清自己的名声，是一件可以理解和令人钦佩的事情。所以10月18日，他对格拉维纳说，那个西班牙同行，他实际上和他相处得很好。他说，看，我们要出海，如果他追上我们，我们将如何对付纳尔逊。因为我们有这么多步兵，我们将把它变成一场陆战。
Yeah, like the Romans. Exactly, the Romans with the Carthaginians. But the irony of this is, of course, this is exactly what Nelson wants. Nelson wants to go in close. So in a sense, Philner's strategy is playing into his hands. Giving Nelson what he wants, exactly. But it's the only way of Wilnoff could conceivably win, I think. You know, if they had fought an old-fashioned sea battle, and Villeneuve would still have lost.
是的，就像罗马人一样。完全正确，罗马人对迦太基人。但这其中的讽刺之处在于，当然，这正是纳尔逊想要的。纳尔逊想近距离作战。所以从某种意义上说，维尔纳夫的战略正中他的下怀。给了纳尔逊他想要的，完全正确。但这可能是维尔纳夫唯一可能获胜的方法，我想。你知道，如果他们进行了一场老式的海战，维尔纳夫仍然会输。
Anyway, Gravina, the Spanish guy, doesn't really, he's not massively convinced by this, but his orders are to go along with what Villeneuve wants, so he says, fine and fair enough. And so that's afternoon the 18th, a very, very cinematic scene. The French and the Spanish officers walked a mass together in the church of the Virgin of Carmen, the patron saint of sailors in Cadiz. And then after five o'clock, these huge crowds have assembled on the quayside in silence, because they know just how bleak the situation is. they start to set off from the harbour.
总之，格拉维纳，那个西班牙人，并没有真正被说服，但他被命令服从维尔纳夫想要的，所以他说，好吧，公平合理。所以那是18日下午，一个非常非常电影化的场景。法国和西班牙军官在加的斯水手的守护神卡门圣母教堂一起参加了弥撒。然后五点钟之后，这些巨大的人群在码头上沉默地聚集，因为他们知道情况有多么严峻。他们开始从港口出发。
It took them all night, and by the morning of the 19th, the first French and Spanish ships have reached the open sea. And this is the news that that morning, the frigates have transmitted to the victory. That stops Nelson from getting calling it over. Yeah, his dinner plans have been ruined. So immediately he springs into action.
他们花了一整夜，到19日早上，第一批法国和西班牙船只到达了公海。这就是那天早上护卫舰传给胜利号的消息。这阻止了纳尔逊把科林伍德叫过来。是的，他的晚餐计划被毁了。所以他立即采取行动。
He orders a general chase to Windwood, i.e. to the southeast. And within moments, the entire British fleet is making sales. And the crews, some of them already are frantically clearing the decks for action. They're rolling up the hammocks. They're removing the bulkheads and partitions. They're stowing the furniture. They're slaughtering the animals or throwing them overboard. But not the dog bounce.
他下令向迎风方向，即向东南方向进行全面追击。片刻之内，整个英国舰队都在扬帆。船员们，有些人已经在疯狂地清理甲板准备战斗。他们卷起吊床。他们拆除舱壁和隔板。他们收起家具。他们屠宰动物或把它们扔进海里。但不是那只狗Bounce。
No, bounce stays there, although he will be hiding in the bowels of Collingwood ship because he doesn't like bangs. So I think it's very unfortunate for a nautical dog. Dogs don't like fireworks, do they? They don't like fireworks or any form of explosion. In Nelson's cabin, you know, obviously, so all his personal, effects are being stored away. And among those, of course, are his most treasured possessions, the pictures of Emma and of Horatia and people who listened way back to our episode on Emma Hamilton. We began with this moment, because even in the hurly-burly of preparations for battle,
不，Bounce留在那儿，尽管他会躲在科林伍德船的深处，因为他不喜欢爆炸声。所以我认为这对一只航海狗来说非常不幸。狗不喜欢烟花，对吧？它们不喜欢烟花或任何形式的爆炸。在纳尔逊的船舱里，你知道，显然，他所有的个人物品都被收起来了。其中当然包括他最珍贵的财产，艾玛和霍拉蒂亚的照片，以及听过我们关于艾玛·汉密尔顿那一集的人。我们从这一刻开始，因为即使在战斗准备的忙乱中，
he's still thinking about Emma and Horatia. Tom, I know you love to read a moving emotional tear-soaked letter. Can I read it again? I think it would be a shame if you didn't. So this is Nelson, and writing to Emma, as the preparations for battle at Trafalgar are being made. My dearest beloved Emma, the dear friend of my bosom, the signal has been made that the enemy's combined fleet are coming out of port. May the God of battles crown my endeavours with success. At all events, I will take care that my name shall ever be most dear to you and Horatia, both of whom I love as much as my own life, and as my last writing before the battle will be to you, so I hope in God that I shall live to finish my letter after the battle.
他仍然在想着艾玛和霍拉蒂亚。汤姆，我知道你喜欢读一封感人的、充满泪水的信。我可以再读一遍吗？我想如果你不读就太可惜了。所以这是纳尔逊，写信给艾玛，当特拉法尔加的战斗准备正在进行时。我最亲爱的艾玛，我胸中的挚友，信号已经发出，敌人的联合舰队正在出港。愿战斗之神以成功加冕我的努力。无论如何，我会确保我的名字永远是你和霍拉蒂亚最珍视的，你们俩我都像爱自己的生命一样爱着，由于这是战斗前最后的书写，我希望上帝保佑，我能活着在战斗后完成我的信。
And if that sounds breathless, it's because Nelson has picked up Emma's habit of never putting any punctuation into her letters. But I think the lack of punctuation just conveys the kind of the hurly, burly sense of his emotions. But this is only one of two letters that he writes there, Tom. So do you want to give us the second letter? Yeah. So this is to his daughter, Horatia. My dearest angel, I was made happy by the pleasure of receiving your letter of September the 19th.
如果这听起来气喘吁吁，那是因为纳尔逊学会了艾玛从不在信中加任何标点符号的习惯。但我认为缺乏标点符号只是传达了他那种忙乱的情绪感。但这只是他写的两封信中的一封，汤姆。所以你想给我们读第二封信吗？是的。这是给他的女儿霍拉蒂亚的。我最亲爱的天使，收到你9月19日的信让我感到非常高兴。
And I rejoice to hear that you are so very good a girl and love, my dear lady. Hamilton, who most dearly loves you. Give her a kiss for me. The combined fleet of the enemy are now reported to be coming out of Cadiz, and therefore I answer your letter, my dearest Horatia, to mark to you that you are ever uppermost in my thoughts. I shall be sure of your prayers for my safety, conquest and speedy return to dear Merton, and our dearest good Lady Hamilton. Be a good girl, mind what Miss Conner says to you. Receive, my dearest Horatia, the affectionate parental blessing of your father, Nelson and Bronte. Yeah, your father. He didn't often write that, did he. While Tom is mopping his eyes, I'll tell you what happened next. So they sail all day
听到你是个如此乖巧的女孩，并且爱着我亲爱的汉密尔顿夫人，我感到非常欣慰，她也非常爱你。替我吻她一下。据报道，敌人的联合舰队现在正从加的斯出来，因此我回复你的信，我最亲爱的霍拉蒂亚，是为了让你知道你永远是我心中最牵挂的人。我确信你会为我的安全、胜利以及能早日回到亲爱的默顿和我们最亲爱的汉密尔顿夫人身边而祈祷。要做个好女孩，听康纳小姐的话。我最亲爱的霍拉蒂亚，请接受你父亲纳尔逊和勃朗特充满父爱的祝福。是的，你的父亲。他可不常写这些，对吧。趁汤姆在擦眼泪的时候，我来告诉你接下来发生了什么。于是他们整天航行
and all night. Overnight, the weather turns by Sunday morning the 20th. It is raining hard. It's very misty, and there is no sign of the combined. behind fleet. Briefly, Nelson turns back towards Cardiz. Have they retreated into port? No. A frigate from Henry Blackwood's inshore squadron signals to him the enemy are still definitely at sea and they are heading eastward.
整夜航行。一夜之间，天气在20日星期日早上发生了变化。雨下得很大。雾气很重，看不到联合舰队的踪影。纳尔逊短暂地转向加的斯方向。他们撤回港口了吗？没有。亨利·布莱克伍德近岸中队的一艘护卫舰向他发出信号，敌人肯定还在海上，而且正向东航行。
At 10 o'clock, that's Sunday, Collingwood is road to the victory with three other captains. They have one last meeting and Collinwood says, when we find them, we should attack at once. Nelson says, no, we're still too close to Cadiz. they could fight till darkness and then they could get away and that's the last thing we want let us wait till the morning when we're all further out we will only get one chance we want the whole day to do this so we cannot waste it midday they're 20 miles southwest of cadiz now and there is still no sign of the enemy and all afternoon they continue sailing and then at six o'clock they get another signal from henry blackwood his frigates have spotted the enemy at least
10点钟，那是星期天，科林伍德和其他三位船长乘船前往胜利号。他们进行了最后一次会议，科林伍德说，当我们发现他们时，应该立即进攻。纳尔逊说，不，我们离加的斯太近了。他们可能会战斗到天黑，然后逃走，这是我们最不希望看到的。让我们等到早上，那时我们离得更远了。我们只有一次机会，我们需要一整天的时间来完成这件事，所以不能浪费。中午，他们现在在加的斯西南20英里处，仍然没有敌人的踪影，整个下午他们继续航行。然后六点钟，他们收到了亨利·布莱克伍德的另一个信号，他的护卫舰至少发现了敌人
30 of them, 30 ships to the northeast. So now you can imagine the tension. Darkness falls. The last night of Horatio Nelson's life. He can't sleep. Out at sea, he can see nothing but the blue lights, the frigates assuring him that they can still see the enemy ahead. And every hour, Henry Blackwood fires a gun from his frigate to signal that all is well. It is a scene, Tom, of unbelievable tension and drama. Now, many great historians. have written about this moment. But I think there's only one book that truly does it justice, and we all
30艘，东北方向有30艘船。所以现在你可以想象那种紧张气氛了。夜幕降临。霍拉蒂奥·纳尔逊生命中的最后一个夜晚。他无法入睡。在海上，他只能看到蓝色的灯光，那是护卫舰在向他保证它们仍然能看到前方的敌人。每隔一小时，亨利·布莱克伍德就会从他的护卫舰上鸣炮，示意一切正常。汤姆，这是一个令人难以置信的紧张和戏剧性的场景。现在，许多伟大的历史学家都写过这一时刻。但我认为只有一本书真正做到了这一点，我们都知道那本书是什么。
know what that book is. And for the avoidance of any doubt, that book is, of course, Adventures in Time, Nelson, A Hero of the Seas by Dominic Sandbrook. And I shall read it now. So I'm kind of giving a reading from the Bible or something. Still, Nelson paced the deck, unable to sleep. Everything
为了避免任何疑问，那本书当然就是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克所著的《时间冒险：纳尔逊，海洋英雄》。我现在要读一读。所以我感觉就像是在读圣经之类的东西。尽管如此，纳尔逊还是在甲板上踱步，无法入睡。他曾经在乎的一切。
he had ever cared about. His king, his country, his friends and family, Even his place in history hung in the balance. This was more than a battle. It was the final chapter in a story that had begun long before he was born. Midnight came, then one o'clock, two, three, four o'clock. The enemy fleet was close, somehow deep in his bones he could feel it. Five o'clock.
他的国王、他的国家、他的朋友和家人，甚至他在历史上的地位都悬于一线。这不仅仅是一场战斗。这是在他出生前很久就开始的故事的最后一章。午夜到了，接着是一点、两点、三点、四点。敌方舰队就在附近，不知何故，他骨子里能感觉到。五点钟。
The rain had stopped. The wind had dropped to a gentle breeze. In the east the sun was rising, the faintest. hint of red spreading across the far horizon. From the masthead came a shout, a sail on the starboard bow, and in the distance he saw them, framed against the rising sun, a forest of masts emerging from the darkness, the awe-inspiring spectacle of the combined fleet, the naval might of France and Spain. it was Monday the 21st of October 1805 the day of destiny had come at last do you know
雨停了。风也减弱成了微风。东方太阳升起，远方的地平线上泛起了一丝淡淡的红色。桅杆顶端传来一声大喊，右舷前方有帆，在远处他看到了它们，映衬在初升的太阳下，一片从黑暗中浮现的桅杆森林，联合舰队那令人敬畏的景象，法国和西班牙的海上力量。那是1805年10月21日星期一，命运之日终于到来了，你知道吗
it's great that is oh god I can't wait for the next episode oh my word well this is going to be our last episode you will know what it is it's going to be the Battle of Trafalgar will Nelson survive it only one way to find out and if you are a member of the rest of its history Club then of course you can hear it right away if you would like to join them go straight into the battle of trafalgar then you can head to the rest ishisthistory.com and sign up there oh it's all set we will see you for episode six of this epic epic account of nelson's life the battle of trafalgar don't miss it bye bye Hello, I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journalist.
太棒了，哦天哪，我迫不及待想看下一集了，天哪，好吧，这将是我们最后一集，你会知道那是什么，那将是特拉法尔加海战，纳尔逊能活下来吗？只有一个办法可以知道，如果你是“其余历史”俱乐部的成员，那么你当然可以马上听到。如果你想加入他们，直接进入特拉法尔加海战，那么你可以前往therestis-history.com并在那里注册。哦，一切都准备好了，我们将在纳尔逊生平史诗般叙述的第六集——特拉法尔加海战中见到你，千万别错过，再见。你好，我是国家安全记者戈登·卡雷拉。
And I'm David McCloskey, former CIA analyst, turned spy novelist. And together we're the host of another goalhanger show called The Rest is Classified, where we bring you the best stories from the world of secrets and spars. It's right, Gordon, and our new six-part series tells the story of John F. Kennedy, the CIA, and Cuba. It's a covert war of botched invasions, mafia deals, and CIA plots to kill Fidel Castro. The CIA has a secret army, the mob has a vendetta, and Kennedy is caught in the middle. So what if the answer to the 20th century's most infamous assassination is found not on the streets of Dallas, but 90 miles off the coast of Florida?
我是大卫·麦克洛斯基，前中情局分析师，转行成了间谍小说家。我们共同主持另一个Goalhanger节目，叫《其余皆为机密》，在这里我们为你带来来自秘密和间谍世界的最佳故事。没错，戈登，我们的新六集系列讲述了约翰·F·肯尼迪、中情局和古巴的故事。这是一场由拙劣的入侵、黑手党交易和中情局刺杀菲德尔·卡斯特罗的阴谋组成的秘密战争。中情局有一支秘密军队，黑帮有宿怨，而肯尼迪夹在中间。那么，如果20世纪最臭名昭著的暗杀事件的答案不是在达拉斯的街头，而是在离佛罗里达海岸90英里的地方呢？
And for our declassified club members, oh, you're in for a treat because we've gone even further. They have an exclusive three-part miniseries that digs deep. into these conspiracies. We've also got as part of that a jaw-dropping episode with Anthony Scaramucci, the mooch himself, who says he has insider evidence that ties the mob directly to Lee Harvey Oswald. All this sounds good to you. You can listen to The Rest is Classified wherever you get your podcast. If you think you know who killed JFK, think you can. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对于我们的解密俱乐部成员，你们有福了，因为我们走得更远。他们有一个独家的三集迷你剧，深入挖掘这些阴谋。作为其中的一部分，我们还有一集令人瞠目结舌的节目，嘉宾是安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇，也就是“Mooch”本人，他说他有内部证据将黑帮直接与李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德联系起来。如果这一切听起来不错，你可以在任何获取播客的地方收听《其余皆为机密》。如果你认为你知道是谁杀了肯尼迪，认为你可以的话。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。